[Laughter]
hey everybody it's friday
and we might be going out after probably
words we probably will let's storm over
us this maybe blow probably blow over
once it blows over we're gonna go out
yeah it's been storming kind of bad but
yeah i mean we don't have to go out we
don't have to leave for like four hours
it's it's a a fetish event
that's right yeah it is that it should
be do we have to pay to get in
no no okay i didn't know better
i didn't know if there was a cover or
anything i don't think so
i think they've been trying to like
implement that but i don't think they're
gonna do it and even if for even if we
went there like we probably they
wouldn't probably i got my sexual
leather daddy outfit you got your
special leather nails yeah i forgot that
it was even though i'm the dumbass that
does all the posters for the [ __ ] but i
i do so many that i can't remember yeah
like what the themes are
so i lose track oh you know what that's
just i don't know why that just reminded
me you remember when we were at the
movies uh-oh is she throwing up yeah she
just do it oh no
she threw up a hairball oh [ __ ] you okay
poop you okay
that's the first time i've ever seen her
do that yeah i don't think she's like oh
she's doing some more oh no like i heard
that noise and i was like explosion
sound yeah
oh pool there's more in there pookie oh
no yeah
you better clean that up before it gets
yeah
i'll pick it up it's not big gross
feeling better
feeling better how could you she
swallowed it ew
it came up a little bit out of her mouth
and then she re-swallowed it she's like
[ __ ] it oh boy you're just gonna throw
it up again
later yeah i don't understand like how
she could have so many hair balls like
how she could have a hairball because i
brush her like a million times a day
every day
i don't want to look at it that's gross
i've never seen her cough up a hairball
before i mean she's short hair
so you know yeah right poop
goodness gracious it's not wet it's dry
looking okay
it's just a little dry you know you know
what she might be doing yeah um because
you know how i she jumps up on the sink
over there and she was like mama brush
me so maybe i brush her
maybe
she goes over there and eats her own
hair out of the brush when i'm not
looking
that sounds like some [ __ ] she would do
there wasn't any fluid
there's no fluid it was just a little
ball of hair
weird a poor little baby that's what
they do you know yeah that's just that's
just the first time i've ever yeah i've
never seen her do it because you don't
usually get i mean short hair cats don't
have like a lot of hair ball problems
uh and i brush her all the time because
she complains if i don't so because she
just likes being brushed yeah but you
know mean
she's got some funny ways man she's got
this new one that she's doing now
when i get in the morning i go take a
shower
and i come out dry off
and then i'll get dressed and then i'll
go back in there and start you know
brushing teeth you know i shave in the
shower
brushing teeth and just getting ready
maybe put some deodorant on or something
well during that phase she comes running
in
and she'll run up to the toilet
and if the lid's up she'll [ __ ] yell
at me and i'll put the lid down and it
should jump up on the damn top of the
toilet and then she'll look at the
window because there's a window right
there with shades and she'll yell at
that children to open the shades i hope
the shade
jumps on on the windowsill and looks out
because that's the only window that
looks out that way that she has access
to
on that side of the house so she wants
to look out that way
that went on for like two or three days
when i did today i let her look out and
then had other [ __ ] i did had to do
around the house and about an hour later
she was
standing in the in front of the bathroom
door in the hallway yelling at me wow
and i was like what and then she runs
into the damn
bathroom looking over her shoulder come
on yeah come on
and then jumps on the windowsills going
ah looking at mrs what and then she
looks out the window and i'm like oh
she wants me to look out the window with
her yeah because when i open up the
window for her to get out there i'll pet
her a little bit and look out the window
with her and talk with her a little bit
she has a little amsr moment but we're
looking out the window together see and
if i [ __ ] don't look out the window
with her
she feels like she's been cheated yeah
yeah and i'll be looking out then i was
looking out the window and she's looking
at me
and i look back at her and then she
looks back out the window and then i
look out there and she looks like we're
looking out the window we're looking out
the window
man it's like a little kid
she is like yeah she's hilarious
the other night though i have to say
she gets zoomy sometimes like in the
middle of the night where she just like
you wake up at four or five in the
morning you hear
like she's running up and down the hall
yeah so she did that a couple nights ago
at five in the morning
and then she ran well she like ran to in
front of the bedroom door and then we
heard her go wow like she growled
really really loud sound like a damn
tiger right and i never heard
tom was like we both woke up obviously
and tom's like what's the matter pokey
and she like just came in there with her
little tail wagon and i'm like okay
dave's in the um
hey what's up shalom y'all yeah yeah you
gonna you going to the club tonight
we're gonna we're gonna be up at
mannequins tonight yeah we'll be there
later yeah we'll be there later
but yeah i just thought i mean i talked
to her about it the next morning i was
like what did you see like you pretended
like chasing monsters in the hall or
something like that i never heard her
make a noise
i know
i was like oh my gosh she's so little
well that's i mean that's what's funny
like i was on facebook today talking to
somebody and um you know how facebook
would be like hey we thought you might
want to look back at this post from
however many years ago so they had a
video that i posted exactly five years
ago
when like the day after we got pokey and
she was so
little she was like a tiny tiny little
kitten and i had like a little video of
her like running around and like chasing
a string and like hiding under the bed
and peeking out [ __ ] like that i'm like
oh my god she was so [ __ ] small she's
still small but she was like way smaller
than
tammy says my female cat cries before
she barfs
oh yeah
it was weird to look down there and i
can't even see where she threw that hair
ball up it was drives
she's i bet she's eating the hair it's
just a round club a ball that is coming
out that i brush out of her yeah like
she's finding it somewhere and being
like ooh delicious hair
i got a i got a shampoo carpets anyway
that's true i got my own carpet shampoo
i got one of good ones
i got one of the electrical i'm so proud
of that he's so proud of election
whole bunch of those
[ __ ] they don't make them anymore
well you can make them but they think
they just want a lot for them and
they haven't improved over the years
that the original was [ __ ] better
uh they just started adding kind of
useless [ __ ] on there just to try to
make it think that they changed it but
they did
anyway uh well that's kind of how you
can just whip it off whip it out real
fast got its own tank and it's real
quick and whip it out real fast whip
that [ __ ] out
on all
so um
tammy said she painted her room
yeah painting the bedroom day have the
carpet turn up what color did you paint
it
yeah man painting is a pain in the ass
it took me forever to just stop cooking
dinner oklahoma onions smash hamburger
smash burgers that sounds good i uh
pulled more
onions
more tomatoes out of the garden pureed
them and put them in that instant pot
and hit saute and cook them down into
just a
tomato sauce and pour that into the
spaghetti sauce i made out of the garden
just from yesterday
every day i got more and more of those
[ __ ]
beautiful tomatoes coming out of there
better than any store-bought tomato and
it pisses me off because right
right when picking day comes on tomato
two or three i'm gonna have a hole in it
yeah it's because the damn birds see it
that's right and they jump in there and
they'll yeah they want to pull a hole in
there and get a drink yeah
well you know you [ __ ] piss me off i
can't blame them really so i gotta cut a
damn quart a little a cut like a little
you know cut a slice out of it like the
size of one of them damn
orange [ __ ] chew candy you know what
i mean you got it like a
you've got to take a slice out of the i
don't know yeah
and you can kind of flush it out with
water the little
you have it because inside of inside a
tomato it's like
pockets
of juice and seeds and it ruins one of
the pockets
but it doesn't ruin the whole tomato
you know you know but you want to get on
it as soon as they put a hole in it you
got to pull it
because you're now it's open to to
nature and you're going to get bugs go
in that hole
so you said every day you got to go
there and check them
and it's always on picking day those
[ __ ] [ __ ] no
they're like oh that thing's they'll go
for the reddest ones well yeah they're
not dumb they're not dumb
and i think it's the same bird
is it the same bird that sits up there
and like chirps like 24 7. it's a bird
that lives around here holy [ __ ] i
should sit out there with a pellet rifle
and wait for him don't do don't pop him
come on he keeps taking drinks out of my
[ __ ] tomatoes man
well they can eat too
don't kill the bird he's eating for free
i'm gonna get some way you want him to
get a job i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get some of that [ __ ] i'm
gonna get some of that food back
put his ass in the [ __ ] pot we do i
don't know if it's the same bird but we
do have a bird that lives in one of the
trees like by the gym window
that seriously i don't know when that
bird sleeps he just chirps or she just
chirps like all the time like really
really loudly like three o'clock in the
morning i wake up and it's like
i'm absolutely convinced that that that
that bird is watching that garden
well yeah of course no one wins what
else do they have to make the move they
don't have the internet
nope nope they're just sitting there
going wait for it wait for it and i
found out what happened to the basil
beijing ate the basil
beijing was getting in the garden ate
all the basil no way yep why would she
do that saw her in there [ __ ]
oh busted yep
it says why isn't that basil growing
what's eating this basil they'll just
see stems [ __ ] beiges
she's so weird why would a cat you
got in the garden ate basil i don't know
that's really funny tastes good she
likes it i guess
that's really weird she's not like a big
people food well
i guess now i have seen cats just eat
like grass like if they had like a tummy
ache or something i haven't doing that
but
i'm thinking about just growing basil
and let beijing eat it
does it go well yeah what are you gonna
do yeah she likes it
somebody's eating it
well she can't eat at all
she eats a new sprouts oh
she's going there that's hilarious i
didn't realize yeah it wasn't growing
and i saw her out there eating it
the culprit she made like a little
wanted poster with beijing's little
floofy face and she laid down afterwards
[Laughter]
yeah that's some good [ __ ] yes
oh my god
that's hysterical it says now doesn't it
it does yeah yeah you didn't tell me
yeah uh yeah dave says yeah i'm going
tonight i think they do they are doing a
five dollar cover charge to keep the
freebie normies away yeah because it's a
fetish party all right so all right
that's that's that's fine
uh let's see so tammy said she painted
the room light green that sounds nice
gonna have area rug that has cream gray
and light green in it really nice wood
floors ooh i wish i had wood floors up
here that means we got to get ten
dollars
yeah where are we going to get ten
dollars
i don't have any cash no remember i um
we deposited i deposited i had some cash
but i deposited it
well they could probably take a card i
would imagine it's the 21st [ __ ]
century
don't they have square or some [ __ ] like
that where it's like or yeah i could
probably just take your card now just
like scan the [ __ ] [ __ ] nobody has
cash anymore come on the [ __ ] you think
this is
or i think there's an atm in there
anyway isn't there an atm in there yeah
probably i don't know there's an atm in
there you know stop by circle k and get
uh something to drink with some cash
back
that's true we could do that we'd be
arizona iced tea drinking that up
pissing it all out and pissing it all
out [ __ ] it on the way can't stand
[ __ ] drinking and driving like that
and your [ __ ] bellies out like this
well see that's the thing whenever we're
in because it only it takes like half an
hour for us to get some mannequins right
and it's like in a car well when i get
well when i get in the car i'm always
like really thirsty so then it's like we
have a circle k just like right up the
street so we sometimes will stop at
circle k and get something to drink but
then we're like in the car like out in
the middle of nowhere and i'm just like
by the time i get there i'm just like
[ __ ] busting you know
uh danny rowling saw the new film black
phone yeah i've been wanting to see that
i've been seeing like some people come
up uh you know reviewing it and it
seemed pretty good pretty good spoiler
alert the kid gets away and ethan hawk
gets killed by him
i think they kind of gave that away in
the trailer
um tammy says do it before your fruit
ripens and the birds will get pissed at
pecking the rocks and think the
strawberries are rocks oh saw a trick
that if you want to keep birds from
eating your strawberries you need to
paint rocks red and put them around the
plants oh yeah
they get confused devious
and they're just kind of like hey these
aren't tomatoes you guys suck
you would think well what is what does
bird's sense of smell like i don't
actually know
i don't know if it'll work
they're saying it will but
you guys said this 99 degrees fahrenheit
outside here in la
yeah i think it was um
it was definitely up in the 90s today we
had i had little uh because i literally
get little weather alerts you know on my
uh pc
and so
it came up
uh uv warning that i get that pretty
much every day and
humidity warning
in heat wave i think came up today but
now it says it's only 75 i'm not sure i
believe that because it's been raining
that's why like for several i don't
think it's 75 degrees
i don't think it's i got three kinds of
tomatoes out there i got the little
bitty little bitty uh tomatoes
like little cherry tomatoes
the other ones i have are kind of like
this
beef steak type tomato
when they they're that big hey
what's she doing what are you doing and
when you cut them open there's red and a
dark red as a
as a strawberry
there's no store-bought
tomato that tastes that way
and the other one i have is a black
tomato it's black blackish green they're
pretty good about that big about the
size of it they don't grow very fast
though i was just seeing which which
ones grow the best what yields the best
those big ones this is the way to go
and uh
my uh what do you call it
some of the [ __ ] i had to abandon it
never really grew
so i used the space up to put more um
eggplant eggplant just heals it's just
like dude we have so much pain
i can eat we were i mean we still have
like a massive we've been eating baba
ghanoush like for the last couple days
and it's like we still have a [ __ ] ton
we went to the grocery store today and
he's like i'm gonna buy like a whole
bunch more pita bread because we have
like so much
rice and well
i got baba ganoo still and then i
i got like five big ol
eggplants
and all that sauce that i made out of
the stuff out of the garden i'm gonna
take that and i'm gonna make um
uh
eggplant lasagna
with uh because i got uh ricotta cheese
and everything
another thing that's growing real well
is [ __ ] oh there's a damn jalapeno
peppers my jalapenos are coming out
really good super good
and then i got these [ __ ] ghost
peppers
[ __ ] hot you just want them getting
super hot
and i made a bunch of salsa
i made um i made made claudius uh
[ __ ] salsa cassana
and real good
it's just
roasted
tomatoes out of the garden jalapenos
onions
a little bit of ghost pepper
and um
cilantro and i just uh
chilled it and blended it it had garlic
too roasted garlic after it's all
roasted
and then chilled it and blended it after
it was roasted it came out [ __ ] great
put it in jars
yeah
yeah what's jardis yeah
tammy says my cherry tomatoes don't even
leave the garden i eat them as i pick
under the other things we have so many
zucchinis i'm overwhelmed made six
loaves of zucchini bread and froze them
yeah geez
i think well you well you made uh that
pumpkin yeah i'm gonna change pumpkins
and like we'll do don't we still have
like a loaf of that frozen or no did we
eat it no god no it's done
frozen stuff's done i made two big old
pumpkin bread cakes with uh cream cheese
frosting it's real good it's kind of
it's kind of like kind of like kind of
like carrot cake yeah but um not quite
as sweet right
but uh
i forgot the name of those kind of
pumpkins i had were they sugar pumpkin
sugar pumpkins yeah sugar pumpkins they
don't get very big there's a lot of meat
in them but they don't
they don't yield as much as up just a
big old [ __ ] country pumpkin i'm
gonna i'm gonna put big pumpkins in
there
let those suckers get you know big
because you're gonna cook it anyway you
know yeah something you make a
jack-o-lantern out of it yields a lot of
food sugar pumpkins they grow fast they
grow pretty fast but they're just
they're too small
it tastes good but i don't i couldn't
really tell the difference
well yeah i mean we said before like i
don't know how cheap the pumpkins are
gonna be this year but usually like
around halloween
actually not even halloween it's usually
like as soon as fall comes along they
got like pumpkins out the wazoo i'm
gonna check these other farms i got up
this road there's like four of them and
it's up in front little signs that i
didn't notice before it says [ __ ]
farm to table
it has everything that they have in
there and one of the things that one of
those places had was pumpkins
then the you pick place they were saying
what was coming into season got it once
we got to keep an eye on that [ __ ] go
down there when when the getting is good
get some of that [ __ ]
they also have those [ __ ] cows over
there
now i know some shit's up with those
cows
what's up with you what's up with these
cows
it makes you wonder what it costs to
like buy in on a cow
you know to feed the cow and then when
the cow's ready you know you get some of
it
let's see
or some people some people will go in on
a cow
then slaughter day comes you divide it i
got that freezer down there now
see so i could store it
it's a lot of meat though
uh yeah there's a lot of meat a whole
cow is i had to go down and get with
that [ __ ] lay down freezer they're
not that much couple hundred
two hundred maybe get a decent one i
could probably get to use one for less
they're around here
put a whole half a cow in there eat off
of it for a year
tammy says has tom ever heard of a is it
kasha kusha it's a pumpkin tasting
squash no i don't think i've heard of
that either i'm sure i pronounced it
wrong
lionex warrior says uh tom is making me
hungry goddamn yeah pretty much
yeah and i have not eaten hardly
anything today i had a tiny well you
made me crab salad
yeah did good craps out today yeah with
fresh dill in it anything like that so i
had a little bitty sandwich of that
and a little packet of
nuts and dried cranberries that was all
i've eaten today and
a cup of coffee
and this strawberry daiquiri thing yeah
jenny's got one of her new little
dresses off i i i got jenny uh dressing
like a girl now
i always dress like a little girl
she looks good though she looks good
she's got the little little uh short
dresses on and [ __ ] looks cute she puts
those [ __ ] goth boots on
the um
yeah
that was popular that last one that you
wore
out yeah
but uh let me see what else is going on
uh
yeah not
just sorry i spaced out for a minute oh
you know okay this is what i was gonna
say remember last time we were at the
movies
and
uh
what is that thing called fathom events
yeah they said oh they were going to
show the thing yeah on the big screen i
think they are
i think they already did it
i don't care
but you know what i was i saw like a
headline or article and stuff like that
they said they made a [ __ ] ton of money
on that like tons of people came to see
it yeah of course which yeah i mean why
wouldn't they
that's like i've never seen it i kind of
like wish that i did cause i remember we
went to see
what the [ __ ] did we go to see
we've seen a bunch of them what was the
last movie we went today
uh
[Music]
now i can't remember
the the one without the [ __ ] uh the
body modification one oh yeah the
cronenberg movie okay
man i just like totally lost it but yeah
i think that there that they there was
an ad for it then yeah but i was it's
weird because i thought it was like a
month away yeah it wasn't i guess not
because like i saw some like somebody
like posted today it's like oh they were
talking about how much money they made
on it and i was like oh [ __ ] that must
have already passed
no maybe maybe they're played and played
in another in another area maybe well
it's probably happening a lot because i
think it's the what 40th anniversary i
think i thought that was for i thought
that was for july
i thought it was too i'll have to look
it up i thought it was like july 17th or
something
danny rowling says
if you like the film stir of echoes oh
yeah i really like starbucks then you'll
like the film black phone it looks good
and it's like i said i've been really
wanting to see it so
i guess it started i want to see that
elvis movie too yeah is that
uh it either starts this week or next
week i can't remember we still haven't
seen top gun we still haven't yet yeah
the cronenberg movie was the last time
we went to the theater
and we're still paying for that monthly
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i mean so that's how
they make their money yeah i'll put some
ice in mine because my
my [ __ ] all just melted
well how'd that happen
mine's still cold
john smith says i love that at the
british antarctic survey before starting
the long winter shift watch the thing
followed by the shining tradition
[Laughter]
that's pretty awesome
zach says hey guys what i miss mostly
food stuff
just talking about food like we usually
do
so we haven't been on that long dude so
i don't think he really missed all that
much we're still kind of like warming up
it was like we talked about food and
like cute [ __ ] that pookie does that's
oh and you missed like uh pookie
coughing up a hairball so there was that
it wasn't on camera or anything but you
could like you could hear it though she
was like
first time that i've ever seen her do
that
yeah he says uh
danny rowling says it's a cross between
stir becca's and the first saw movie oh
all right
intriguing
that's not exactly the the way that i
thought it was going to go but i
actually kind of like i like that i like
that angle i like that angle
yeah if you guys haven't seen star of
echoes i'm sure probably most of y'all
have but
i always kind of like recommend that to
everybody because it's based on a
richard matheson book
and it came out the same time as
uh the sixth sense
so it kind of got creamed but
honestly i think it's a little bit
better than the sixth sense but i mean
the sixth sense is good too but i'm
always kind of like bummed out that it
got
kind of buried under the juggernaut that
was this that was the sixth sense you
know
oh
it's time for some pokey action
what are we gonna do hi sweet baby we're
gonna be on tv
she's like yeah i'm on tv
okay
she's like how long i gotta stay here
and get smooched down
oh
she's such a good baby
dave says gotta go see you tonight okay
we'll see you uh later on
like i said where i already got ready
before so i didn't have to worry we just
shut it down
get just get get in the car and get out
of here all i got to do is put shoes on
yeah and i'll be
ready to go
based on
oh wait a minute
based on a joe hill short story
what is the black phone is it
i didn't know that
i liked a lot of joe hill stuff has
anybody like watched that series
nosferatu that was based on his book
because i feel like i started watching
it and then like i forgot about it like
i didn't really
but i liked his other um i liked his
novel horns was really good and actually
the movie adaptation of that was pretty
good too with daniel radcliffe i was
into that
okay i got um two
two of the um screens for the shirts
where they got omega man done
and i got uh canon
canon studios canada studios looks
really good
i took one of my old um
stretch kind of
shirts uh tank tops that i had stopped
chewing that please shot a mega man on
it went to go cook it and it [ __ ]
bubbled and it's because uh i forgot
that dye doesn't only works on cotton
yeah no it works on cotton
and then i just went like that and it
just [ __ ] rolled off like glue
but it's not a shirt that i wear much
anyway so it doesn't matter i mean yeah
it has to be cotton or like a cotton
blend
right that's really the window
situation
i need to get some um
smalls of the tanks
you know the tanks that you got me i got
a bunch of mediums they're too big
they got to be small that on that
particular brand
yeah how much were those things you know
i have no idea well like i said there's
if you go i'll show you one day if you
go to the jiffy jiffy shirt site there's
like 40 bajillion like every single
thing there's like 40 options oh for all
of them for every single thing and it's
like so they don't always have the same
stuff like someone's like this is 100
cotton this is just one this is soft
feel cotton this is this this is this we
got to find this one remember this one
feel it so it's one well it's not gonna
help yeah it's not gonna help unless i
look on the tag or whatever because it's
not solid it's like it's got lines in it
hey the way it's knocking out you know
what i'm talking about yeah it's got
like lines yeah like it's ribbed like
it's ribbed for her pleasure yeah
there's
it's something about the weave of that
shirt and then the way they're cut
usually it just it's just better than
what you know
they feel more expensive and when you
shoot something on it it looks better it
has like texture i like how it looks
kind of pooky what is your deal there's
like depth to the image you know yeah
i don't look i don't like the ribbed
ones as much
like to make the shirts because it seems
like i'm always kind of like worried
that the head is gonna like smear you
just gotta go through it kind of light
and it just
there's something about that the image
looks like it's 3d or something
yeah there's texture to it i like how it
looks i like the soft feel cotton and i
like the women's cut ones like i'm not a
big fan of like just the
i like how the women's cut you have to
get like a women's cut but then like the
men's cut is just like the generic shirt
yeah and i'm just like they don't fit
right you know what i mean on me the
men's ones don't know the women's don't
fit right on you no the men's ones don't
fit right on me i'm just saying like
they always say like the they always say
the men's ones are like unisex i'm like
not really not really
i'm like why don't you just call them
men's shirts because that's what they
are yeah it's like i got boobs and stuff
it doesn't fit the same it doesn't fit
the same
but you know
zack says uh i've been getting back into
my obscure late 60s 70s european cinema
it's my favorite air in movies i think i
love how experimental movies from then
are without sacrificing story yeah i
mean
i'm probably i'm gonna say i probably
still think the 70s is my favorite era
for movies of any kind like horror
movies i mean obviously i like movies
from every era but i still think the 70s
is my favorite there's just something
about
that
yeah my daiquiri just turned into a
drink drink
it's good though on the rocks it's not
bad no tastes like tastes like like a
red death
yeah that's exactly what it is yeah
i mean we drink them slow you know what
i mean yeah when tom brought it up here
he originally brought the drink up in
that in this big massive
mason jar yeah that was like all the
blenders covered because he had to get
the blender in there i'm like dude i
have little bitty hands like and i'm
gonna have to go over there like that
and pick it up because my hands are too
little they'll like pick it up yeah with
one and i said i'm gonna drop that so we
probably should put it in like another
[ __ ] glass just the one at a time
thing you know that that my little hand
can fit man man
men don't normally drink daiquiris you
know make you gay
they make you gay they make the average
[ __ ]
but of course but not you of course of
course not man this just [ __ ] soften
my masculinity just slightly but well
that's okay
i was asked zack zack that's that's how
zach flipped i was reading i was reading
an article the other day and apparently
there's a thing i don't know how big of
a thing this is but
dudes some dudes apparently think it's
too
girly to go to like brunch and have
mimosas so they have to call them a man
can't remember how you make it i think
it's basically just a mimosa but it's
got like extra vodka in it um and
there's and i'm just like really
really i mean is your masculinity that
fragile
then it's like you can't even let
anybody see you drinking them the best
this is the here's the thing i've never
heard of that okay i've never heard
i think so i haven't heard of it no i
haven't heard of it either but we made
that up no i was reading an article
about it yesterday and apparently like a
lot of people had heard of that
it's a thing sony made that
well yeah somebody made it up but then
like it became a thing yeah and i just
like thought that was funny yeah but i
was just like [ __ ] man come on
get some but get some [ __ ] umbrellas
in there put something except stick with
like pineapple chunks on it come on it's
okay just drink what you like no one
cares brunches brunches that's
california or something that's that's
you know brunch is for everybody that's
that brunch is amazing i don't know why
people like why why do you want a [ __ ]
on brunch i don't [ __ ] on brunch yeah
well not you i'm just saying people in
general like why it's not girly it's
that brunch is for everybody brunches
for you woke up late you're drunk you're
hungover exactly that's exactly what
it's for it's like i'm gonna go get some
waffles and also maybe some oysters
what i like is that
that damn
um
[ __ ] what they call that
it's an omelette but it's got
shrimp with the [ __ ] cream sauce in
it what's the name of that omelette oh i
know what you're talking about yeah what
the [ __ ] is that that's what you want
[ __ ] for brunch
yeah
it's got
it's got a creamy cheese sauce and the
inside's white and it's got little gulf
shrimp and it's inside of omelette i
forgot what that [ __ ] is called [ __ ]
yeah see that sounds delicious yeah
really have that with some great
different grits on the side no you don't
need grits just that and then well i can
use it if i want to
yeah you could you can you can [ __ ]
drink champagne and orange juice with
that no problem
always remember what the name of that
[ __ ] omelette was go ahead and drop
that i feel like i know that but i don't
but i can't think of what it's those
things are [ __ ] good man
do you remember like um was it memories
of india they used to have a sunday
brunch yeah where you go because they
had free like bottomless mimosas yeah
and it wasn't they didn't have a lot of
like breakfasty type food but they had
like a um they had like a buffet so you
could just like go in there and they had
all of the food like laid out
we went there a couple of times i did
get a mimosa once but maniac's going to
brooklyn
his gosicles are playing okay he got
sickles yeah
sassy is there what's up sass how you
been says a man moses sounds gay i know
ironically man moses is way gayer
than their father that's what i'm saying
that's not
that is not a real thing some
some
some woman made that up about straight
men or some gay men as hating on
straight men made that no man moses is
gay that's gay
it's a trick it's psychological
it's psychological warfare
it's gay men made that story up to try
to get straight men to order man moses
so they know who to target this is
we're gonna get that one that's he's a
virgin okay that's what that's what
they're doing that's what they're doing
he's a booty virgin yeah he's yeah
you gotta be careful
[Laughter]
you gotta stay vigilant you gotta stay
big
okay
oh my god
you gotta resist it you drink you're
drinking [ __ ]
strawberry daiquiris you can't they'll
pile up on you you might flip
i mean you never know we could just be
sitting here right now and there could
be like a whole
like wave a whole tidal wave of gay men
will come in here and try to get all up
in your booty hole you never know that
could happen
it could have
good
it's stuck awake
you never know what's going to happen
well you know it's weird it's like i
haven't thought about daiquiris in a
really long time but like i said we were
at the
at the grocery store today seriously i
went to because tom's like well i need
to go to the grocery store and get like
some mixers for tonight and i was like
okay well i just need to go no poop no
stop putting one of your books out
that's it and it's a book that's falling
apart already well she that's why i put
like all the shitty ones on the bottom
because i know she does she's tearing it
up look at [ __ ] pieces flying i know
like i said that's why i put all the
shitty ones on the bottom he didn't have
anything to do so you had to have
something to do right okay she's like
yeah i'm just she's eating work on that
for a while
she's sneezing bless you sweetie we'll
be eating the paper and that won't
happen
but like so i
literally needed like two things i was
like i need like a couple bags of coffee
and like one other thing
and so we go there and tom's like yeah i
need mixers and he ended up buying how
much soda did you buy i bought um
12 12
12 liters no no no no no 24 liters
it was 12 2 liters
he just keeps putting two liters in the
[ __ ] and i'm just like jesus christ
because i don't really drink soda so he
was gonna drink all of that [ __ ]
it was four two liters for three dollars
yeah the publix brand yeah public brand
they're good they're real good um
and
they didn't have every one of them that
i wanted but
half of them were were diet which i
don't know why they [ __ ] call them
diet men don't buy diet
we buy zero calories yeah even though
it's the same thing or we bought you
they need to [ __ ] reword that [ __ ]
you know it's like let's make the
package black in a black and red with
like
slanty letters and then we'll call it
coke zero cokes yeah
yeah no women men don't do diets okay
we call it a regime
okay
he's a
man right you guys are so funny yeah
we do a regimen you're just a
never-ending source of amusement
they need me as a marketer i understand
how to name [ __ ] i get men find that
[ __ ] [ __ ] right and left but you
don't call them mimosa a man moses
okay
that's that's straight out of a [ __ ]
bdsm leather bar i don't you know what i
don't think that
the that the ingredients like orange
juice and champagne i don't think that's
necessarily the issue
i think the issue is the glass they
serve the glass because it's like a
flute and it's too weak
so they're going to put well that too
but the reason they make them weak is
because most brunches have bottomless
memories and they don't want everybody
like flopping around falling into the
waffle irons and [ __ ] like that you know
what i'm saying so they have to like
yeah because otherwise you're gonna get
like a whole like gaggle of cairns in
there
the grander says isn't a shrimp omelette
with hollandaise sauce just called a
shrimp almond hollandaise sauce
i don't think it's hollandaise sauce
it was uh [ __ ]
it might be i don't know we might have
to like google that [ __ ] because
with cream of shrimp omelette no what
was it called
man y'all are making me want to look it
up
it's a shrimp omelette but yeah i can't
remember [ __ ] it came with
i'm gonna find the [ __ ] name of it
but yeah but what i was saying so we we
were at the grocery store like i said to
literally get i was just going to get
coffee that's it and he was going to get
you know like orange juice and like [ __ ]
to mix with in sodas and stuff and then
we were going by the mixers and he's
like well you want some more zing zang
like to make some more bloody mary's and
i was like nah i think i'll put that on
a rest because i really love bloody
marys but they give me really bad
heartburn so i just i only have them
every now and then and we were like
looking at all the drink mixers and he's
like ooh strawberry daiquiri and i was
like oh my god that does kind of sound
good let's get that so that's how we
ended up having stroke it's very
refreshing it's very like summer drink
caitlyn higgins says what's the best
store brand product
you've ever eaten
would be um on a publix ice cream that's
you know what i was gonna say that exact
same thing i was gonna say that exact
same thing
yeah and but all the flavors are good um
i think the best one of theirs because
sometimes i get others like bluebell or
whatever i don't buy a lot of ice cream
to be honest with you but every now and
then we get some
um
one of the best ones i like their coffee
ice cream like the coffee with the
chunks in it and their peppermint is
good and i think we got one too like
around christmas that had like
peppermint stick in it i want to say
okay what it was it's a it's a shrimp
bomb that was bakamal sauce in it it's
just like a white yeah
it's awesome
okay uh does it have a name or no no
okay so we were just trying to think of
a word that exist yeah it didn't have it
we'd have been really frustrated the one
stop it pope
the one that uh the one she's trying
what she wants attention
the uh
what i mostly remember from was when i
was a kid
out um out in california
there was a um
restaurant that served him the name of
the restaurant was [ __ ]
jose
jose something or other
it was a funny restaurant it was a small
california chain
and it was a
owned by a guy who was
half
irish american and half mexican
half southern you know from southern
california
and it was jose something another mick
something with an irish name on the back
i was gonna say it was it was it like
yeah
was it like jose mcdougally
[Laughter]
somebody from california might know
exactly what it was i'm talking about
and they had that omelette there they
would serve it for [ __ ] brunch and it
would just fly out of that damn
restaurant
oh yeah and it was it was good and and
the it was
in very early fusion restaurant yeah all
right it was mexican food
and american food mixed together and and
with kind of an irish
kind of theme mexican irish theme that
i feel like you didn't really see that
in a widespread way until like fairly
recently yeah and then they were doing
this back in the 70s
late 70s
well yeah i kind of feel like probably
in california yeah california ahead of
the curve yeah
um granthar says trader joe's orange
chicken you are actually not the first
person that has said that that was
[ __ ] delicious
we don't i don't we have a trader joe's
around here i think but i don't think
we've ever been there but apparently
like a lot of their brands are really
good too they i think um
they have a bunch of like ready indian
meals
um
and a lot of people have talked about
like how good those are like they buy
them for their work lunches and stuff
like that and they talk about how yummy
they are but i've never uh never had
them
but yeah you're i've heard several
people say their orange chicken is
really good
um john smith says for irish mexican
crossover there was a mural artist named
juan o'gorman
it's funny i guess i wouldn't really
think about it like unless somebody
pointed it out you know what i mean
unless it was something like really
obvious
i don't know i guess
but they're talking about
um
grampar says who has a bigger root tommy
lee
steve mcqueen or tom jones
[Laughter]
um
do we know
well there there isn't any proof but
other than tommy lee because that that
proof has been [ __ ]
uh uh cemented forever on video that him
and [ __ ] pam on the damn yacht
so
at least you could prove it all right
evidently tom jones was no joke
put cassandra peterson aka
elvira sent her to the hospital
she said i'm sure that wasn't a fun time
he went and he he [ __ ] went in
through the back door and [ __ ] her up
and she had to go get some stitches
every day god damn it yeah
was she okay with that or did he know
it's kind of it was kind of like an
accident type of deal i i think
you know like he was aiming for the uh
yeah so he was aiming for the other one
and he's just like what she told she
told that story on howard stern show
i don't know
she said he was like a 40 ounce beer can
man yeah i would not want to 40 yeah and
then uh
but evidently [ __ ]
legend has it the biggest [ __ ]
in the world was milton berle
i've heard milton berle and roddy
mcdowell yeah like also like had super
big units evidently milton berle was
[ __ ] dangerous and he was a leather
daddy i think
i don't think he was straight but
evidently that sounds good he'd come at
you with that thing and [ __ ]
would have to run
okay
you could be like a godzilla movie
everybody's like running down the street
yeah i don't think the world was
straight
oh our side rolling up on you in that
[ __ ] wheelchair
please please tell me that somebody has
done like a sort of godzilla porn parody
that has like some giant with a big huge
schlong like walking down the streets of
tokyo and everyone running away in
terror yeah
and i'm not gonna look it up i just
wanna know in uncle milty's defense i've
heard that he was [ __ ] hilarious
he was hilarious
and um
he did a lot of drugs evidently i mean
not a lot of drugs but he would get
drugged up at parties and [ __ ] was
just crazy
and was keep people rolling it was funny
as [ __ ]
which is you know you remember from
ironside he seemed real [ __ ] serious
but that's not how he was
evidently he was [ __ ] funny
wait was that that wasn't a moment no no
no no yeah i was like wait am i am i
having a stroke that's okay
dude from ironside oh what was his name
oh [ __ ] now that now i blanked but i'm
pretty i was like yeah i thought it was
milton no no wood no the dude from
ironside was
was was evidently [ __ ] like a gay
dude with [ __ ] he was just [ __ ]
huge dick and would [ __ ] show it to
people and try to [ __ ] people and [ __ ]
and get high
i may have him raymond burr raymond burr
that's right i think he was raymond
thank you dj maniac raymond burr
evidence i totally blanked on it too
yeah right and i'm like and i'm not even
drunk in my defense i'm just getting
older that's where i got i got recruited
anymore
but i think milton berle also
that's what i heard that's why i didn't
like question you until you started
doing the wheelchair thing and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you going to merge
those two together
i think
the names are kind of similar and
and
burr and burl
or
i don't know for some reason i just got
him confused and evidently both of those
dudes were [ __ ] huge
uh but i think
raymond burr right yeah by the name yeah
i think that's one i think that's the
one
that was that was the gay dude who was
[ __ ] um just funny as [ __ ] and uh
i'm gonna have to look that up yeah well
because there's i think we were talking
about this we might have talked about
this a little bit like when we were
talking about um whatever happened to
baby gene yeah yeah
or that i put up earlier today um i kind
of feel like a lot like victor borno and
like a lot of actors like that like you
kind of had to be closeted back then
like everybody kind of knew but they
didn't really want the information
getting out to the public because you
know
about about raymond burr you guys can
probably dig it up in the internet so
you come back and
confirm it for me i don't want to open
up another page but i believe that's the
one
because i haven't talked about that or
thought of that in a [ __ ] long time
that was something that came up like
[ __ ] over 20 years ago it was [ __ ]
hilarious back then
the story and i think i think it was him
they were talking about stories of him
at parties and [ __ ] hollywood type
parties it was just mixed crowds and
[ __ ] would come out [ __ ]
with just a shirt on with his [ __ ]
dick swinging and trying to [ __ ] some
dudes you know what i mean who's
straight you know but he's like making a
joke out of it that he's the dude's
running away and everybody's laughing
you know and there's there's women in
there and [ __ ]
that's how it was
but that's i think that's the way some
of those hollywood parties were back in
those days
sherman was so [ __ ] [ __ ] wild yeah
they were so coked up cooked up [ __ ]
drunk
they all had kind of a bunch of money
and they they were all freaks too all
those people were [ __ ] like it's like
being in the carnival so
and they all knew well like i said it's
not like it wasn't you can't well you
can't really if you're famous yeah if
you're rich and famous and actually
party with each other actually
you don't even have to be rich if you're
famous if everybody knows who you are
you can't have a normal life right i
mean you just can't right so they
partied with each other and they would
just
they all knew each other's foibles and
[ __ ]
and uh definitely they'd have a good
time
you know it's like being in the circus
or it's any other kind of scene you know
yeah you just kind of yeah just all kind
of hang out together they're just
hanging out together yeah john smith
says true guys like tab hunter had to be
closeted for the majority of their
careers yep that's true like tab hunter
was one of the ones i was thinking of um
but yeah there's yeah that happened a
lot back then and like i said it
happened to victor bono who was uh the
guy that was in yeah whatever happened
to baby jane yeah um
mr 88 says maybe ask cynthia plaster
caster i haven't thought about her for a
long time
do you remember that woman she was like
a um well they call her a groupie but
it's like she she made plaster casts of
all the rock stars
dicks crotcheler areas
yeah
for like an art project
did that dude have to stay rocked up the
whole time
i don't remember i don't know if they
were fully erect were they i can't
really remember it's been like a long
time give me more viagra you know you're
trying to
[Laughter]
try to keep it up for a long time
trying to imagine it
yeah i don't know i it would take a
special dude to be able to like maintain
an erection like while somebody was
putting like the
plaster apart
for four hours
yeah because that takes a while to dry
yeah so i think not
tying down [ __ ]
steel wires around the base your dick
get that [ __ ]
you ain't going nowhere now i got you
i mean i thought they were i don't know
i don't think they were erected if i
remember correctly but
i remember she was kind of like a thing
in the
i don't know i remember hearing about
her like in the late 80s yeah barnum was
on batman 66 played king tut that's
right yeah yeah he was uh
flaming king tut
he was good though in every run of his
roles
he was in the evil too yeah do you
remember that yeah cam guy says liberace
was was gips which stands for gay in
plain sight
my old man used to laugh like hell
whenever he was on johnny carson's show
yeah
[ __ ] uh liberace was a legend though
and [ __ ]
i told the story before on the show you
guys probably heard four of you regulars
evil knievel had two
and evil knievel was a [ __ ] psycho
okay and he and he was all man i mean he
was more man than a man should be they
should have taken some man away from him
okay
that's too much
[ __ ] dangerous okay and he wouldn't
shut his [ __ ] mouth okay
the evil knives was a [ __ ] beast okay
he was a modern-day gladiator he was
literally
entertaining
crowds of people that wanted to see him
die
that's what those stunts were about
is that
knievel's like i've just realized that
these people really want to see me die
yeah they'll just keep coming i mean if
you ask him that they would deny it but
that's absolutely why do you think
people go see like watching nascar and
[ __ ]
they want to see wrecks man knievel's
stunts were [ __ ] outrageous and they
really were dangerous they were no
safety equipment just a helmet
you know i think his riding suit was
leather but there wasn't even any pads
in it all right
doing jumps on a harley davidson that
was never meant to be in the air
a harley davidson only lasted one jump
the frames would [ __ ] snap on impact
most of the time
uh it's just a
crazy man [ __ ] crazy and the snake
river canyon jump with [ __ ] rocket
all right
a two-bit rocket that wasn't even really
a good rocket okay
anyway
knievel had uh and he and kaniva was a
psycho
he was crazy beat some dude near half
the depth of the [ __ ] baseball bat
for writing about his wife okay he was
not
a freaking normal dude i mean
he was just a little excessive yeah and
he was southern it [ __ ] that's part
of it too you know i think it was from
where [ __ ] oklahoma not oklahoma uh
was it okay texarkana it was around that
area it might have been oklahoma or
sexual canada's arkansas it's arkansas
yeah arkansas oklahoma something like
that anyway um
he had two
legendary heroes
elvis
and liberace
so he likes a little bit of the glam
he thought liberty when he was
because you know
knievel was paid basically to entertain
at casinos that's where some of those
jumps had happened and casinos would
[ __ ]
pay to have him stay as hang out as a
guest and [ __ ] you know what i mean so
he was making money just
to show up and be an [ __ ] really
okay
and he would eat for free at the [ __ ]
buffets and stay at the hotel's casino
hotel for free and get to see all those
free shows
and he wanted to see liberace because
liberace was working his casinos and he
loved liberace evidently
the whole thing about being suspended by
the from the wires and flying around and
the whole show
and the music
and liberace doing his thing and he
thought that was the greatest show on
earth so
when you saw knievel
his little riding outfits and his show
was modeled after elvis presley and
liberace
but he believed liberace to be the
bravest performer of all
and it's obvious from the wording of
what what
knievel's saying is because
he's gay in plain sight
just like
i kind of feel like yeah because i kind
of feel like most of the time like i
said back then in those days you really
had to like stay closeted kind of
pretend you were straight
um or you could go the liberace route
which goes so over the [ __ ] top
that
people were like yeah he's super gay but
it's all right because it's almost like
i don't say it was almost like a
caricature but he went so far over the
top that it was like okay again which is
a thing yeah which is strange that was
his branding yeah but then he would
never admit to it
he never admitted to it well yeah that's
kind of what you did back they asked you
and they said why didn't you ever come
out everybody knew and he goes no i had
a lot of female friend
older female fans that had come out like
that or broken their hearts
and i think there was something to that
yeah because like old ladies back then
ladies they wouldn't have known yeah
he had he had millions of old ladies
that had a huge crush on him and they
knew but they were hoping
that he was available i can make him
straight yeah
there's a fantasy they had good luck
with that yeah
[Laughter]
so what he's talking about is he's
talking about uh [ __ ] um
[ __ ] hags is what we call you know yeah
and you know [ __ ] it's like
my buddy toby got a bunch of them
you know [ __ ] but that's
for every one gay man there's like
[ __ ] set you got seven or eight
[ __ ] overweight
women that follow him around they love
him
you know
just how it is well like i said because
a lot of times they're friends and [ __ ]
yeah well because a lot of times it's
like they're like a man but they don't
have like all the [ __ ] that you can't
stand about dudes
and they're getting attention and
they're having a relationship with a guy
they're having a relationship with a guy
who's not
that they're not in a relation not in a
sexual relationship with but it's
there's affection and friendship and
there they can talk about things and
yeah it's that nothing wrong with that
yeah
and you look if and if you look at toby
he's all man so
yeah you know and there's that pie in
the sky fantasy i think the women have
and that's what you're like well maybe
one day he'll he'll he'll realize that i
love him you know that's what they're
doing you know
yeah sometimes i think that's part of
what it is granthar says question do
women like men with coke can sized dongs
or do they cringe when boom boom time
begins
um
a woman yeah it depends on the woman and
it depends on the person there are some
women that are size queens
i think generally most women would
probably be like oh [ __ ] here we go
because probably it's like painful you
know what i mean um
but you know you never know
and like i said it depends on the dude
that the dick is attached to also yeah i
mean we're not real body parts yeah
that's the thing just because just
because you're [ __ ] built like that
doesn't mean all the women watch if
you're a [ __ ] dick then no they want
the women wanted the entire package yeah
um
a lot of it has to do with [ __ ]
cultural
expectations and what's norm in a
culture like
jenny and i are actually speaking from
the point of view of [ __ ]
north america this wasn't a deal in
korea
you know korea let's just say
the the ethnicity it's very homogeneous
and uh
korean girls were uh
size queens yeah
because of expectations
they had heard things and
man i don't want to get into that
very curious about [ __ ]
the um
what they what they were hearing about
and what they saw in western porn movies
okay
because that's not really the situation
going on in korea so much so they uh
want to try that out and
if you don't
if you disappoint them then they're not
going to be then they're going to be mad
because they have certain expectations
you know
so but in korea no they were size queens
if she was with you it's because she
wanted to [ __ ] get in your pants
and she's trying to get your pants
because of something she saw on video
yeah watching the porn with the big old
yep
big old schlongs yep
that's really funny but the dude their
dudes are like that too though
you go to japan
if you're a well-endowed
woman you're going to be very popular
very popular because
eastern women are tend to be thin at
least especially in that although in
those days
from what i've been seeing though a lot
of i think maybe because of fast food
higher protein diet a little bit more
fat in the diet
they're growing people in in the east
are growing bigger and they're getting a
little a little more shapely okay but it
didn't used to be that way and korean
koreans were when i was in korea in the
80s they were small thin people
they're a lot bigger now
they're a lot more western looking than
they were
diet i think has a lot to do with it
well yeah probably i mean fast food is
kind of proliferated across the world
yeah
because they ate a very low protein diet
when i was there
so i
i don't know what that does to puberty
you know
john smith says anthony perkins had to
be so into in the closet he was
practically in narnia yep that's true
or poor anthony i didn't know he was gay
yep you got from psycho yep
he got married though didn't he
a lot of them did a lot yeah it's called
the beard okay
i mean especially if they were like
really really famous yeah you know
sometimes the studio would be like hey
he grew up with christopher walken
yeah
their parents were in the circus
together or something
if i remember correctly i don't have to
look that up yeah i think they were but
yeah yeah he was like super closeted
like most of his most of his life
which is kind of a shame
i wonder if like um that was just the
way it was back then yeah i know well
because his son oz perkins makes movies
the scene the gay scene was a lot uh
more secretive
yeah you had to keep [ __ ] on the dl yeah
but i've also heard some guys that went
went through that
uh interviews with them they said they
kind of liked it that way it was more
exclusive there's more seniors well i
get that like i said it's it's just kind
of like what we're always talking about
it's like oh we don't like the normies
coming in the goth club and [ __ ] like
that i get it like it's more fun when
it's illicit yeah but then on the other
hand some tighter crew on the other hand
you don't want to just be like walking
down the street with your boyfriend and
get your [ __ ] ass kicked either you
know what i mean so i don't understand
so there's that
it's kind of like
it's kind of like you know
uh dj says do you guys know about marlon
brando and richard pryor they were a
thing for a minute apparently i had
heard not surprised me i had heard that
brando was evidently uh was was
evidently very experimental he he didn't
believe in um he didn't believe in
physical gender
you were whatever you were you were like
he thought he thought of people as just
souls
you know
and that's okay if you if you said that
you if you called him bisexual he
probably would go no that's a limitation
he's not even he was one of those guys
he was ultra
theoretical you know what i mean
but uh so that's why i said earlier on
another show it says you had to be
careful with marlon brandon because you
sit there talking to him and [ __ ]
he'd also just give you a kiss
you know
but you had to just say this is brando
you just go okay yeah all right bro
that's good and it's love you know what
i mean it's not he's not trying to
attack you he's just sucking his love
you know
well i kind of he was crazy to be honest
i mean yeah he was crazy
but i don't think that's i don't think
that's a that's a crazy way to look at
things no it's not i mean because like i
i like to take people on an individual
case-by-case basis everybody's got their
own [ __ ] going on you know what i mean
it doesn't really like matter
a lot of [ __ ] like doesn't matter
there's a lot of recorded interviews
with brando and he's [ __ ] loaded and
he's having a good time and he's talking
to people and it'll be like a real
straight up serious interview type of
deal and brando's talking he's being
deep and [ __ ] then all of a sudden
just goes
and kisses dude on the lips you know
what i mean
well thank you mr brandon
that was that's just how how he was you
know
but um
he it was also part of his
brand
he knew what he was doing the brando
brand the brando brand all right tm yeah
that's how he was he was an entertainer
yeah
mr 88 says also called a lavender
marriage
yeah that's right i had heard that
phrase before
like if they if you married for the sake
of like the public if you're famous
yeah a lavender marriage
shelby melissa says i think men
overthink this there is someone for
everyone
pretty much i mean there might be some
exceptions but
the fact that
serial killers get fan mail
um
that should actually it's depressing but
it should also like conversely like
cheer you up a little bit because it's
like look if there's somebody for those
[ __ ] then probably there's
somebody out there that's well women
love danger
some women love danger and they love
[ __ ]
bad boys that's the ultimate bad boy and
also it's a way of for them that they
can get attention on themselves
i think that's part of it but it's
always i think a lot of it you know what
a lot of it might be too i think that
some that type of woman one they usually
have daddy issues big time uh and two
they usually think oh well
it makes them feel special because it's
just kind of like this person like
killed you know it was ted bundy or
whatever the [ __ ]
he killed like all these other women but
he won't kill me i'm special i can he
loves me more than anybody but like he's
they don't even care like which is
[ __ ] up i mean i'm not saying that's
good that's what like super [ __ ] up
but yeah i think that's kind of where
they're coming from because they it
makes them feel special because they're
like well he's not going to kill me
because i'm special you know i mean all
those other [ __ ] were just victims
daddy ghostface says he heard that
brandon james dean hooked up
that wouldn't surprise me either but it
also wouldn't surprise me that brandon
james dean would have lied and said that
they hooked up
all right the whole idea in that era was
to get attention
and to seem real
cutting edge and like different from
everybody else and not following any
rules
and breaking boundaries nowadays that
would just be [ __ ] nothing you know
well yeah it's like it would just go
under the radar because no well like i
said and i in a way that's good um
because you know back then it's like ooh
it's like all boundary breaking which
like i said i can see how back then it'd
be kind of cool because it was elicit
but
now i'm glad that it's not really that
big a deal david bowie and and um
mick jagger
the rumor was they had a thing going on
and angela bowie that's where angie the
song angie that
that mick jagger was talking about but
other people who knew them
recently from our member came out says
no they made that up
they made that up
they were friends but they they weren't
you know
but who knows
who knows yeah i mean we weren't there
we weren't there so it's like it could
have happened it could have not happened
and then they were just like ooh let's
tell everybody yeah but they were the
publicity you have to understand that
david bowie
was an artificial homosexual
he maybe was bisexual but he he he was
an artificial homosexual okay he was not
a cross-dresser he was not
he that was art that's what he was doing
he had very he knew how to play
the uh uh he knew how to play
the gay thing the gay community they
were very
wealthy
and famous
with patrons of the arts
that helped bowie's
career early on because they want they
loved his material and what he wanted to
do and they would help finance his
artistic projects
probably knowing that he was
that it was artificial
but it didn't matter it was art and
they're bringing that expression into
the mainstream
which helps
mainstream society at least understand
what the gay scene is going through
so it's more like a an advertisement
slash
artistic uh
examination of what that scene was about
david bowie's last video is him [ __ ]
dancing backwards dying of cancer going
back up into the closet
he went back into the closet and his
final words were
tell them i was a closeted heterosexual
i really hope that's true because yeah
iman said that those are tell them i was
a closeted heterosexual
it was it was the whole thing was was
show business
i mean that's right up there with either
those curtains go or id yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's oscar wilde's last words
yeah
now that he died
yeah
it's just that life imitates art and
artists
intelligent artists and good business
people know how to entertain and
it's a storytelling exercise they're
taking you on a journey
and that's one of the things david bowie
did he was a [ __ ] master a master
okay he was really good
and he was not a great musician but he
put out great music
okay i mean look what he was responsible
for too i kind of feel like it was
largely david bowie and like a glam rock
and stuff like that came out in the 70s
that kind of like went a lot into a lot
of the quote unquote gender bending
stuff that you saw in the 1980s like
with new wave and all of that kind of
stuff yeah and then like hair metal now
when it comes to great gay musicians i
would say elton john was better
but in term just from a musical
standpoint but when it comes from art
artistic
standpoint and um
uh uh what was gonna what i was gonna
say just from
as a performer
i would say david bowie even though like
i said he wasn't gay
it was act
but that i'm not going to take anything
that doesn't take anything from him
though
it was still great material
great material
but when it comes to
now the thing with the thing with elton
john is that elton john a lot of the
material that he sang about was written
by his straight friend who they were
friends for life yeah bernie topping
that wrote all that music
but um
when it comes to homosexual performers
elton john was a real thing
yeah he was gay
[ __ ] great he was a great performer
though [ __ ] good music real good
yeah i i the older i get the more i can
appreciate like the when i was younger i
didn't like him as much i listened to it
now well yeah i think we were talking
about that before where it's just kind
of like sometimes like a lot of the
music that would came out in the 80s and
70s and 80s and i was just kind of like
ooh mainstream music gross and it's like
i was because i was like into more
underground [ __ ] yeah but then like the
older i get i'm just kind of like oh you
know what that [ __ ] was really cool
because now you have like some distance
on it it's not ubiquitous right um you
know it's kind of all like gone into the
thing yeah but now some people might
come back well what about what about um
um
dude from queen what's freddie mercury
from queen that's what you know what the
thing is is that if you were really kind
of look at freddie mercury he'd probably
tell you he was bisexual all right
because he messed with women too
even though i think he's primarily more
into guys he messes women too
um
if you want to say he's gay then i'd say
he i put him
i'd put him above
elton john but if you say no he's
bisexual then i would put elton john
above him if you don't talk about if you
want to rank them that way i don't like
looking looking at people that way
yeah because it's kind of like the
difference yeah i mean they're the
styles of music were different it's like
there's just
right
but when you're talking about like
non-cis gender [ __ ] freddie mercury
when it came to overall
that same thing you say non-cis gender
but metal you know what i'm gonna say
rob alford yeah rob halford's god okay
yeah when it comes to the [ __ ] metal
and everybody's going to tell you that
and he's still around
yeah that [ __ ] is still kicking yeah
still okay this still sounds good
sophie saw him live just a couple months
back she said
it's [ __ ] fantastic
yeah he's great
camp guys talking about famous last
words
oh ben franklin yeah burn that essay i
wrote about farting
i had heard that that was his last ones
too because he did write a whole essay
but well didn't ben franklin he was wild
as [ __ ] well i think it was a satirical
essay i think about this and this is a
while back that i read about this so
please forgive me if i'm remembering the
details wrong but i think that he was
writing about
some kind it was either some kind of
drug you could take or some kind of
thing that would make your fart smell
like perfume or something like that i
think it was satirical it had something
to do with the pot and i was like what
are you talking about that's a good idea
he was talking about
yeah i think i remember what you're
talking about i vaguely remember that
yeah somebody had explained it i don't
remember all the details but he was
making fun of the british parliament it
was something like that yeah it was like
a satire but that's like really fun i
hope they did that was his last words in
that essay i wrote about farting
gramthers is asking some questions
random questions name the one book that
had the greatest impact on your life
is the first question yeah um
ooh that's kind of like a hard one it
would probably be one that i read when i
was younger
because
okay i know like okay this might be a
weird choice but i'm gonna say
clive barker's books of blood volume one
because that was the book that i read i
had read the [ __ ] before that
but that was the first book that i read
that i said this is what i want to do i
want to write horror like this guy
that's and that like really like kind of
i mean i was into horror before that but
that was the first thing that kind of
like opened up the possibilities of like
what you can do with it you know what i
mean because it was so [ __ ] weird
oh there's some good comments up there
if you back up
well i know but i'm trying to like okay
um what is the next bucket list item on
your agenda oh geez i don't even know i
don't even have a bucket list
um i don't know pretty much the only
thing i want to do is like take another
vacation at some point
because i'm like i'm tired
uh how many x's do you still keep in
touch with and why
i don't really look at it that way
i we party with a lot of our exes
well actually your ex went back to the
[ __ ] whales so yeah and like honestly
like one guy i don't ever see him
anymore um the other guy i talked to
every now and then like maybe every six
months or something
but i don't ever see him anymore yeah oh
that guy when he got married right who
the one that got married remember that
he hit that one actually had he was nice
yeah but
yeah but there he got divorced oh they
got divorced kind of good they weren't
married that long yeah she was nice
though yeah he was he was cool and i saw
her a couple times too and she was
really nice but yeah he doesn't i mean
he's
he was not in he was not a guy he was
like goth adjacent he was more like an
indie guy he was into rolling to the
fetish scene and [ __ ] like that
um but he was okay with the gossip and
everybody liked him he was a good guy
yeah he was like yeah he's super yes me
and jenny knew each other at that time
but we were dating other people at that
time yeah yeah our history goes way back
we knew each other before we were
[ __ ]
a thing
we became business partners before we
were a thing i think didn't we
more or less yeah i mean we were friends
for a long time yeah before
yeah because like i said we were still
dating other people because i was dating
a couple other people at the time yeah
well not at the same time but like
sequentially
but a certain surfer i think his name
serpent said that
bowie's last words were telling i was
straight yeah it's not quite what he
said but yeah that's what he meant
he said uh
tell them i was a closeted heterosexual
i mean that's that's awesome yeah it was
funny and that's why he was dancing
backwards into the damn closet in the
closet behind him as he was and people
were like boy what's wrong with these
videos why is he looking that way why is
it so dark he's dying
dying of cancer
singing all these things he went out
like a g kim had a good album his last
album was good his videos are really
good and it's about him
joining the dark going back to the black
star in the center of the universe where
where [ __ ] major tom was and
everything you know so he's the whole
bowie verse is now [ __ ]
being folded back in on itself and
closing his whole entire life was an art
and sciences yeah yeah and you really
have to respect that commitment yeah i
mean yeah
seriously you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on and they got the damn astronaut
suit with the skeleton in it and [ __ ]
oh major tom's dying yeah yeah dead yeah
yeah
says goodbye yellow brick road is genius
it is yeah um we put some ice in there
for you yeah that'd be good okay oh man
here we go i'll empty some of it out
i wasn't really like thinking about it
yeah
stop talking about elton like he's dead
he's still gay
i even kind of liked that rocket man
movie i know it didn't get like huge uh
we actually saw that in um
the theater and i i actually quite
enjoyed it i guess it didn't really get
much uh get good reviews but it will
uh let me say doo doo doo yeah bernie
toppin
uh
yeah dj maniac said i love that rob
halford got a bunch of homophobes to
dress like leather daddies and they had
no idea i think that's what that's what
delights me about the whole thing is
that everybody like all these guys
like all these [ __ ] rooms like from
some [ __ ] trailer parks
no hate i've i've grown up in a trailer
park too but uh but so i know what i'm
talking about and so like they came to
these like heavy metals just yeah like
with all this [ __ ] [ __ ] on it like oh
my god they're probably thinking
we're so badass
look hilarious
we were kind of like thinking about that
because
because we were talking about top gun
because the new movie came out and
oliver harper put up a retrospective of
the original top gun which i have to i'm
not a huge fan of the original top gun
you know what i mean you guys know i
don't really like that cocky tom cruise
kind of especially when he was younger
i'm just kind of like knock it off but
um he did kind of bring up the whole
homoerotic thing but the hilarious thing
was that growing up in the 80s
i kind of feel like
i don't really know if straight people
that were watching top gun i'm sure i'm
sure gay people knew
but straight people watching top gun i
don't know if they picked up on it
because tom was like when i watched top
gun like back in the 80s nobody was
thinking oh it's like super homoerotic
but if you watch it now it's like really
i mean come on it's like really really
obvious but back then it was just kind
of like yeah super manly
i don't know i just thought that was
like really really funny but yeah if you
watch it now it's not just top gun it's
a lot of movies that came out in the 80s
i mean look at [ __ ] what was that
what's that one um commando look at
commando for christ's sake holy [ __ ] but
it's just funny
shelby says do you guys decorate for
halloween
i'm already thinking about my theme this
year especially with inflation plus kids
kept coming last year yeah we usually
just do
i mean
we had just last halloween we had just
moved into this house
so we didn't really have a lot of time
but basically we do like the lazy
people's decorating like outside where
we just have like those projection
lights we have like projection lights
have like ghosts on them and
what do we have like we have ghosts bats
and something else i can't remember
but yeah we have like a bunch of those
projection lights that we put all over
the front of the house like bats and
ghosts and stuff we didn't get
did we get a lot of trick-or-treaters
last year because we were here last year
right uh yeah we moved here before yeah
we didn't get that many it wasn't that
many but i mean we might get more
um dan michael says what in june yeah
well the thing about it if you guys
follow any um halloween
channels like jade the libra or things
like that uh june man she she does deep
dives man she has like spreadsheets and
everything um
a lot of stores start putting their
halloween [ __ ] like not all of it but
they'll start putting a little bit of it
out like a little bit at a time usually
starting in june
depending on the store usually most
stores will have some [ __ ] out by july
but she does like a big she did a video
the other day that i watched that um she
had like this whole list of stores and
she was trying to like extrapolate like
when they would be putting their
halloween [ __ ] out um you know depending
on like what they did last year
um
[Music]
usually i mean a lot of stores i think
wait until after the back to school [ __ ]
is over because it's like they need all
the room for up for all that kind of
stuff
but
a lot of stores will start putting a
little bit of halloween or at least like
fall stuff out in june because that's
when she starts doing her halloween uh
decor hunting videos she calls them she
like drives all around she lives in um
uh kansas city i think
and so she drives around
and sometimes she's with voltaire like
because she's friends with voltaire
whenever he's in town so they'll go
around like driver and she drives to
like michael's and home goods and like
uh you know ross and all this kind of
places like looking for halloween
decorations so and she finds them
usually starting in june but you know um
holy parish of doom says we realized rob
was gay when we were teenagers in the
80s the whole leather boy thing was
rather obvious yeah i kind of feel like
in the 80s i guess i didn't really
i didn't think of it well i kind of
thought of it but not it wasn't really
that big of a deal for me i was just
kind of like i guess i thought about it
in the sense that because in the 80s
because i was really into like new wave
and um post punk and stuff and so there
was like a lot of quote unquote like
gender bending going on with that and so
you know my grandpa would get all like
grouchy about like duran duran oh
they're all gay blah blah blah i'm like
no they're not and actually duran duran
none of them are gay but you know what i
mean like boy george was obviously but
you know some of the ones that they
thought looked gay because they had an
earring or whatever yeah that was that
was the thing we're not we're like
straight
[ __ ] supermodels yeah so you couldn't
really tell so i was just kind of like
whatevs i didn't really care one way the
other i'm just like just make some good
music and you know and whatever
uh and i wasn't worried about it beyond
that but i guess
i don't know i wasn't into heavy metal
so i don't really know yeah i i started
listening to uh metal and i guess
probably around
82.
and i remember by the time i was
probably around 83 84
judas priest is one of my favorites at
that time really i was listening to a
bunch of [ __ ]
but around 84 85
i bought one of their albums it's called
sin after sin
and
you guys remember what it was like when
you bought an album back in those days
man you put your [ __ ] put it on the
record player you had your headphones on
there were a big ass [ __ ] headphones
sounds like you had the lyric sheets
took the lyric sheets open the gate
folder you sit there
i'd be in my room i was in brazil at the
time
i'm looking out the window over sao
paulo [ __ ] sneaking [ __ ] shots of
whiskey
you know yeah because really you're not
underage in brazil [ __ ] 15 anyway no
such thing no such thing
that's why my mom catch me you know man
i was sneaking cigarettes
and i was listening to the sin after sin
album and we would listen to an album
almost back to back sometimes
it was like an experience it's like
listening to an opera
he had side a and side b b looking at
the record album
learning the lyrics
well cena descent didn't come with
lyrics not printed lyrics
there was a song on there called raw
deal
and i couldn't make out everything he
was saying
but i realized what he was talking about
he's talking about [ __ ] leather daddy
club but i didn't know where fire island
was in those days
yeah
and he was talking about [ __ ] i
walked in yeah nowadays well [ __ ] hulu
has a show called fire islands
and honestly
i i remember hearing about fire island
being like that was the place all the
gays vacation yeah back in the late i
think the late 80s i first heard about
it yeah and he started saying these
steely [ __ ] leather dudes [ __ ]
with their bodies heavy slinking away
for some action
if you're lyrics
possibly and then they're going to like
[ __ ]
you know they're like a couple cops
playing rough stuff
we're playing right now a couple cops
playing rough stuff in new york fire
island [ __ ] they're like what the
[ __ ] is it meanwhile every gay dude is
like oh yeah yeah playing rough stuff
you didn't know that yeah no i knew
something was uh and then and then later
on it goes and there he was so mean and
cruel
[ __ ] and and
what the and i was going this must be
that uh that bondage stuff that they
talk you know when you're like 15 you
know
this makes me that bondage thing all
those kids are doing
and i'm like gay dudes do that you know
i'm like [ __ ] you
i can't do that yeah but that started to
like break
oh okay okay i get this now all right i
understand this now that like the the
whole
the whole vibe of the band started to
make a little bit more sense once once i
realized that this is
hyper masculinity okay this is warrior
homosexuality that we're talking about
here you know
and it made a lot more sense then
well yeah yeah
that took about a year for me to kind of
come to that
like when you're a kid especially back
in the low information environment
before the internet it takes longer for
you to decide oh yeah that's what it is
because you didn't have access
to
porn or you know [ __ ] magazines or
that that were on that subject this is
all super underground [ __ ]
i'm guaranteeing you man back in the 80s
average [ __ ] metalhead dude had no
idea that that's well that's what dj
maniac was laughing about like he got a
bunch of homophobes like stressing up
like leather daddy yeah without knowing
not without knowing without knowing what
they were doing that is which like i
said that always kind of like yeah it
was funny looking back on it
now oh we know that
yeah
yeah they got you they trick
[Laughter]
that's so cool i hope he did that on
purpose because that's like pretty
hilarious
wait that was his coming out song but
yeah that's one reason why there wasn't
any written lyrics on that album
rob was like i wonder if he was like
really stressed out like when that album
came out he's like i wonder if they'll
like know what i'm talking about he
talks about it yeah he talks about it he
just says well we didn't have al we
didn't we're not gonna put the lyrics
out on that album let's we're gonna let
it be vague let them figure it out yeah
no rob came back [ __ ] eighties early
eighties
or that might have been late seventies
that might have been late 70s i think
that might have been 79 when that album
came out
it's just that you had to read between
the lines which that is classy if you
ask me
it comes out it has you know what i mean
it's not in your face motherf what it is
in your face
but you had to come to that conclusion
they weren't where he wasn't wearing it
on his sleeve
it wasn't branding the band
he was just stating a fact this is well
the thing about it is that probably and
it didn't really define everything he
was still doing his his music well and
the thing about like i said because the
band wasn't really like about that yeah
so he's like well i want to like say who
i am yeah but i don't want to like make
it like oh we're a gay band right yeah
that's not what it was
he was just kind of like talking about
his own experience it was power metal it
had love songs in it and stuff like that
the the the it could fit anything it had
[ __ ] songs about [ __ ] being
dangerous and on the edge
you could read into it
whatever you wanted and make it fit
into your situation if you [ __ ]
listen to the screaming vengeance song
screaming for vengeance
it's probably a [ __ ] thing about
[ __ ] oppression about the oppression
of the [ __ ] gay bondage scene that's
what it says well just the gay scene in
general the game the gay scene in
general but the stonewall right but it
but it could but that could fit anything
yeah i mean it doesn't come out and just
say that's what it is well it's more
universal
so anybody that kind of like feels like
they've been like [ __ ] on right yeah so
to me it's more classy
when it's like that
because it's more accessible to
everybody
and then later on they go what is that
exactly about what i'm talking about
this oh okay yeah i see that now yeah
see it actually makes it stronger
because if you
if you don't leave it open to
interpretation you've now narrowed the
bandwidth down see
you want to widen the bandwidth so
everyone yeah i mean depending on what
you're doing i mean yes so everyone can
access
the emotions that you're talking about
and if you you relate to that you say
well what were you talking about when
you wrote it i was talking about this oh
okay yeah i see that i see that yeah
yeah but that's like analogous to this
situation
i just wanted to fit this one together
right
yeah
so they were more artistic back then
you leave everything open to our
interpretation
shelby says i love jade the libra she's
beautiful yeah i love her too and
honestly i really really love [ __ ] i
will watch a 45 minute video of her like
cleaning out her closet and like
arranging her closet just cuz like i
don't know like her whole like
personality is super cute
um i don't know she's just super cute
and like when she drives around with her
with her fake skeleton yeah in the
passenger seat yeah looking for
halloween decorations maniac comes out
because rob didn't come out publicly
into the late 90s when he was doing the
industrial rock and we all knew by then
already yeah exactly that's funny but uh
if you were a fan though
of judas priest
you really would have known that he
actually came out in the very late 70s
on the sin after sin album
and that was long before
the screaming for vengeance album or the
british steel album and he came out in
the in the prague rock era he had come
out but you had to be paying attention
big respect for rob
yeah he's a great artist
dj maniac says oh voltaire is always in
town for me yeah he is he has an
apartment in new york city honestly one
of my favorite videos of his because if
you didn't know like voltaire other than
being like a really cool like uh goth
musician also has a little youtube
channel where he's all like goth
decorating yeah and he did a great video
where he was
redecorating his teeny tiny new york
city apartment bathroom yeah and it
ended up looking really cool like his
whole like aesthetic is
black white purple because purple is his
thing
so
i mean the [ __ ] that he did in there was
like really cool and he does like videos
about like making like crafts and all
this other kind of stuff but he seems
like a like a nice dude chevy melissa is
with us today if you guys want to go
ahead and subscribe to her channel she's
got a new little channel she's been
working on
um
and then john smith says the best thing
about duran duran is named after the
build for barbarella that's right
um and then uh
john says frankie goes to hollywood was
the best gay band i love frankie they
were good but i also i also liked um
i mean that song relax is good two
drives is good all that [ __ ] is good
another good one though was what was the
one that had they had the um
they had the
it was a damn
orange cd that came out had a bunch of
little things on the other one that move
out
didn't move out oh is that yes yes or
yazoo if you're yeah
yes yes i believe was a gay band also
well now that was um
that was the dude vince clark from who
was
in erasure yeah racer yeah and that was
and alison moyer yeah yeah yes was great
i liked them real good i would say that
was a gay band but the the lyrics not as
gay as a racial [ __ ] because erasure
that was i don't i mean vince clark is
probably gay too but like andy bell was
like flaming yeah yeah like uh eraser
and they're kind of like an iconic like
gay dancer and yet in the yaz band
though it was just kind of universal it
was just music and [ __ ] it was really
good i liked it good club music from
that era
allison moyer did some good uh solo [ __ ]
too yeah i think it was a lot better
known in the uk than here but yeah i
mean she had a great uh voice
you know what i mean
uh
let's see yeah um yeah shelby's talking
about like halloween and uh dan michael
said halloween to corporate now i used
to like it but now it's just big
business yeah but that's everything
almost now but the thing about it is
like well you don't have to like partake
in that you can just like do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do with it you know
what i mean i [ __ ] love halloween i
wish halloween was all well actually i
kind of wish it was all the time but
then i kind of don't because then it
wouldn't be like
special you know because i remember when
george michael came out it was all over
the news yeah i remember that man
i remember my uh senior year in high
school i [ __ ] left michigan and went
back to brazil to do my [ __ ] senior
year
of high school let's go looking at the
water to sao paulo
and [ __ ] that was like one that was
like the best year of high school was
this was a senior when you had that [ __ ]
made but i tell you what
and they played
in all the brazilian nightclubs they
[ __ ] played george michael [ __ ] 24
7.
all the high school girls [ __ ]
listened to [ __ ] george michael
the faith album was out
that [ __ ] that was almost everywhere god
damn here it was here too yeah by that
time i kind of left metal behind i was
[ __ ] into more into goth and [ __ ]
uh you know
really good [ __ ] like cold wave and
new wave is coming in but i got sucked
into george michael george michael's
[ __ ] hits were really good uh there
was something about
the tone of that music and the lyrics
i even liked william yeah i'm not i'm
not i laughed at wham when wham first
came out i mean they were very uh they
were very perky they were very perky i
was in the metal at that time but those
are some good pop songs those are some
good pop later on you're like yeah it's
pretty good it's pretty good i mean i'll
tell you right now if like if i'm at the
goth club and they play wake me up
before you go go i'm dancing that's it
yeah it was pretty good no shame
[Laughter]
but i remember [ __ ] i remember being
a senior in high school just with
[ __ ] mad respect for george michael
[ __ ] those videos i was like man that
is the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is so
heterosexual it's not even funny that
[ __ ] damn
no wrong but boy it seems to be that way
at the time it seemed to be that way at
the time i was like that guy's on top of
the game man
but not gay didn't know
but his videos were [ __ ] great
massive appeal to the [ __ ]
young heterosexual mainstream [ __ ]
loved it
they loved it it was sexy sounded music
faith
all that [ __ ]
father figure
those videos
yeah auto walk and just i want your sex
i want your sex and [ __ ]
uh i think i got laid on several
occasions just because of those
albums because of those albums yeah well
women who i'm saying women they were
girls actually high school girls were
ready to give it up behind that album
yeah
so thanks george
thanks george
he's passed away sadly yeah
but uh yeah
and he died huh yeah yeah yeah he wasn't
he wasn't but no he wasn't old i think
he was a 50 i think wouldn't he
or in his 50s yeah
but that's the thing like i didn't again
i didn't really i thought probably
like i i didn't like his solo stuff as
much i like it more now than i did at
the time i liked wham at the time
because i was like that's super poppy
but it's also like really good and
really catchy because i was like you
know i wasn't above that
so i liked that
but
i didn't really think about like izzy
gays you know i'm like i don't know
maybe maybe not i wouldn't think i was
like could go either way i wasn't even
really thinking like i said i didn't
really think about it all that much i
was just kind of like hey if you make
some good ass music i don't really give
a [ __ ] i just saw it and and and just
recognized him as a straight guy
it was like oh yeah yeah i was vibing
with that because i could feel the same
way the writing was good
okay if if a straight teenage guy's
vibing with it and goes that's right
we're gonna get some as [ __ ] then
you've written it well he's probably not
what he was talking about though he's
probably talking about dudes it's just
that i read into it
uh
but from that you know the wham era and
everything you're talking about
they were pretty good but looking back
on it
um
and i liked it at the time but i didn't
want i i was kind of resisting liking it
it was tears for fears
remember that oh well yeah of course
it's like serious for fears i think but
i think they were better
yeah uh yeah i did like to well they
were a little more
serious and a little darker yeah um yeah
i really liked sears for fears yeah i
liked um shout everyone wants everybody
wants to rule the world
uh head over heels right all that [ __ ]
still good and i actually liked that at
the time
and i still like it now yeah
wham i was just kind of like wham i was
like i didn't want to like it cause like
i said it was like so poppy but i was
like man this is so good though i mean
you know tears for fears was a lot more
like the pesh mode i felt yeah it was
kind of like that no i liked i liked the
patch mode also during that time yeah
they were kind of new they came out and
i was like that's pretty good
and then uh it seemed like right after
that [ __ ] front 242 came out i was
like oh no i like that that's what i
like
when 242 came out it was harder
yeah yeah well you know vince clark from
yes yeah
was in depeche mode for their for their
first album yeah i don't know the
interplay between the first album which
was called speak and spell yeah uh was
super gay okay um if you if if you have
never heard it yeah um it's good it's a
good album it's like it's a it's a gay
dance album pretty much gays were always
on top of [ __ ] club music yeah but he
left and then he went and he was in yaz
and then he formed erasure with andy
bell and they got like massively
successful obviously and then depeche
mode like you know
well didn't like didn't the guy from
dipashmoor just die the other day
yeah he did wasn't the singer was it no
no it was one of the guys in the back
was it uh andy fletcher i think was it
andy fletcher
yeah holy [ __ ] i can't believe that i
used to have [ __ ] posters of the
fashion model over my [ __ ] walls
everybody people are aging out and a lot
of those guys were into drugs
yeah probably heroin and stuff dan
michael says poor andrew ridgely nobody
cared what he was yeah they really
didn't i kind of andrew originally i
wonder what ever happened to him he was
the other guy in wham okay by the way
and i'm just always kind of like yeah he
always really got upstaged yeah my
george michael that it's like after i'm
sure he did [ __ ] afterward but it's like
nobody everybody's like whatever he
didn't stand out
george michael stood out and i remember
i remember those videos of george
michael and that dark-haired guy and
[ __ ] george stood out
and looked uncomfortable in that band
it just he just looked uncomfortable in
that van if you asked me i remember i
saw some stuff live
think that dude was hitting on him
and he wasn't didn't want to be with him
that's some speculation but i mean maybe
i don't know you're both gay i don't
know much about that he was trying to
get this
all i remember was the wake me up before
you go go video where george had like
these
really really bright white
little bitty shorts on we were laughing
and he was like super
enthused yeah we were laughing at that
[ __ ] i was like wow he's really excited
to be in this video
ram sounded good but we were laughing at
that [ __ ] live the way they looked and
everything it was kind of like uh it was
it was it was on par with later on
millie vanilli coming out we would laugh
at that [ __ ] even though the [ __ ] the
sound of melanie vanilli was great
but that wasn't them it turned out those
were just some dudes they hired to
[ __ ] lip-sync to that music yeah that
was some that was like hey the guys that
were actually saying it's like you guys
are kind of fat yeah yeah can we get
like some hot model types yeah
skinny [ __ ] black dudes that look hot
and have them dance and we'll say that
that's you're saying
that's not who is [ __ ] singing yeah
how'd that work out yeah not so well
okay right there
actually those one of those dudes i
think killed himself later on didn't he
oh did he
was it rob or fab
i think so he tried to do his own career
and it didn't work and then i think he
ended up committing suicide can you
imagine like that would be god
those dudes really couldn't sing
i mean that's what like we kind of laugh
about it and it's like a punch line but
in a lot of ways
then i kind of like back up and i'm like
wait that's like a person those are
dudes those are like people and it's
like they have to like live their life
and they're just like a [ __ ] punch
line in history and it's like that's
really gotta be that's gotta suck yeah a
lot
yeah so next talking about who's who
cared about who so i feel camp guy says
annie lennox and the arrhythmics were
awesome during that time period oh yeah
i was i really liked the eurythmics man
um you know sweet dreams like uh here
comes the rain again like all oh man
they actually said that rob killed
himself i don't know which one that one
yes
yeah rob and fab yeah that was their
name yeah
it's a shame but
they became the la they became a
laughing stock yeah
and um
that was back when there was no internet
and everyone was [ __ ] channeled into
a very narrow bandwidth and that was
almost kind of like the collective
consciousness
of america
when it came out that those dudes were
not the dudes actually singing they just
became a [ __ ] laughingstock and that
one dude [ __ ] killed himself behind
it
nowadays if that would happen it'd go
unnoticed that they weren't they weren't
the singers
i mean they wouldn't everybody would
like talk about it for a day
and then like some other [ __ ] would yeah
and then that dude would open up a
youtube channel and get more hips on his
[ __ ] youtube channel than he did on
the original band be some [ __ ] like that
i mean probably i kind of feel like
which like i said in a way it's like
people decry [ __ ] nowadays but in a lot
of ways i think it's like kind of better
because back then
you said man it was the light-skinned
german one yeah yeah for you youngsters
to know what we're talking about
just look up millie vanilli
millie vanilli was a band that had
[ __ ] really good music this was like
late 80s early 90s i kind of feel like
it sounded great it had a great look it
was basically two black guys with long
dreads and matching outfits and they
were kind of funny looking kind of
shorts and kind of like something out of
culture club i remember there's like
some matching dance moves maybe
synchronized dance moves and a girl you
know it's true and [ __ ] that's
literally the only millie vanilla i know
[ __ ] those girls those dudes are
getting laid like crazy man all the
[ __ ] white girls are [ __ ] going
crazy all right
turned out they weren't the ones singing
they were it was they were lip-syncing
the whole time to dudes who actually
wrote that they were overweight guys
and they got busted in the lamest way
possible it was a live show yeah and
they're out there on the stage
singing the song and for whatever reason
yeah because they didn't have the
technology back then it was a record it
started skipping and it started to skip
[Laughter]
and they tried to like cover it up being
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i was like a
record really like don't you guys have
like [ __ ] 10. they started
investigating it turns out they had
nothing to do with the music it was just
hired dancers yeah they couldn't yeah
yeah they couldn't sing at all
yeah dj maniac says the d.a.t tape got
stuck yeah okay
i mean we know all the details i thought
it was a record too but
and and here's the deal i never saw that
we just heard that and that was enough
to destroy that whole [ __ ] band i
mean i saw it and i didn't see it live
but i saw it later and they were [ __ ]
top 10
they were some top 40 at least they were
[ __ ] they were top 10 i think they
were selling yeah
yeah they were like a sense and then
after that it was like immediately like
they just became awake
and nothing became a laughing stack one
of them killed himself behind it he was
he was kind of a light-skinned german
guy
they were
they were bad guys um
i didn't know where they were from
but they were cute man [ __ ] and them
girls [ __ ] loved them
i remember girls [ __ ] talking about
oh yeah that guy oh he's so cute isn't
that you know
and um there was nothing else like that
i was way into alien sex being at that
point
yeah so i was just kind of like okay
whatever
at that point but yeah and it's like i
you know and i'm not gonna lie i laughed
along with the rest of the world yeah at
that because i'm like
okay whatever fakers i didn't really
care that much because like i said i
wasn't like a fan or anything but
they
for me it was like a flash in the pan
they came out of nowhere everybody was
talking about i heard the song and
everything i was like yeah that's a
catchy [ __ ] song
and i looked at him and says yeah that's
a good look
okay and then then just like
felt like weeks later it's fake
out of nowhere boom
yeah it was just another time yeah there
was like a [ __ ] punch line yeah every
like every um you know nighttime talk
show everything like they were all
making jokes about them yeah so can you
imagine
how i mean like i said nowadays and they
were just hired to do it i mean nowadays
it's like really
diffused i guess because it's just kind
of like you don't have the entire wrath
of like the whole culture coming down
because everything's like so
fractured
but
back then like everybody knew yeah dj's
given more details see what it says
uh i know a little bit about primitive
recording tech their vocal tracks were
recorded on dat for live performances
okay yeah so i kind of thought rob was
from germany
yeah okay they look like twins
to me i thought they were like twins
they looked to me they looked the same
they just had that model they had yeah
they like models
and i'd had to go back and [ __ ] look
at it it's been since i was a kid that i
saw them
and i remember they had these little
black outfits on they were like black
shorts and black jackets and i remember
like the knee-length shorts knee length
shorts because i remember it's like what
are you even doing man yeah they were
like dressed almost kind of like
pilgrims in shorts that's what they look
like
that's how i that's how i remember
[ __ ] man what i remember did they
just like put pilgrims in shirts that's
how i remember it was kneeling
shorts kind of like dudes from from
jewish bar mitzvah bar mitzvah [ __ ]
kids or something like that
with the [ __ ] little hats and yeah
but that was kind of in style at the
time yeah yeah because i think that can
it came from uh i mean it was knee
length black it was knee length shorts i
remember white shorts they might have
had black ones too and then like they
had like a just a regular like white
collared shirt and like a black jacket
and then they had the dreads and then
they had the hats but like i said that
wasn't that
that's kind of what the style was at the
time it was almost kind of like
something that
was kind of harkening back at that time
to uh boy george
it felt like something like yeah but not
not as extreme yeah not as not gender
bending yeah just kind of
because boy george had a whole i had a
whole aesthetic going yeah
they it was almost kind of like a like a
much watered down like version of what
george was up to
dj maniac said they did the same thing
with martha wash yeah that's right and
cnc music factory used her voice and
hired a model yeah that's right that uh
cnc music factory everybody danced now
you know that wasn't her huh yeah that
wasn't uh yeah the woman you see in the
video that's not who's singing
it's just it was just a [ __ ] totally
fake construction from the comp yeah
they're like well we have to make a
video we don't want like you
heavy people well they knew what they
were doing in the video they knew what
they were doing
it was about marketing and sales it was
just corporate
corporate [ __ ] and in those days
your videos for your songs really
dictated
where you were going to be and how many
albums are going to sell so it was about
looks
if you didn't have in the looks things
that changed from the early 80s with you
know some of this
some of the stuff that you know
some stuff from the early 80s if you
look at the old videos so hit songs are
a joke you know like well i can't
believe that was a hit song how low
quality that video is the videos by this
time well they didn't have a lot of
videos they didn't have room they had to
be slick as [ __ ] it was a new media yeah
and everybody had to look great in them
you know because millions and millions
of people were going to see it
so they had to if you didn't look that
good they had to clean it up they had to
put [ __ ] a bottle in there [ __ ]
pretending to be you that you weren't
gonna tour anyway
most likely there was especially if it
was like a dance try yeah if it was a
dance track you weren't gonna tour they
were just gonna [ __ ] sell that song
and that album over and over again
you know
it's made sense
but there were still a lot of real good
looking talented artists like you know d
light remember that band yeah do you
like it they did a lot of good for
grooves in the hat
and she really did look that cute that
was her and that and that really was the
band so they weren't all fake
you know well i kind of feel like both
of them weren't but yeah you know i mean
obviously if you're gonna be in a band
and you want to like make videos and be
famous yeah you do have to at least put
you don't have to look like a supermodel
but you do have to kind of like put your
best foot forward i guess yeah yeah but
i don't know i kind of feel like
in a lot of ways people kind of felt
betrayed about that because it's just
kind of like that's they weren't really
singing they were just listening
you know what i mean
john smith says you should see the
behind the scenes footage from when they
were recording the live aid do they know
it's christmas song boy george is being
such a [ __ ] to george michael
i probably saw that like a long time ago
because honestly i really really like
that song
um even though the words are like
super cringe like nowadays
but that's still like a good christmas
song
and i was really into that because you
know it was like everybody like i said
it was culture club it was duran duran
it was like everybody that was a
bananarama it's like everybody that was
like famous back then like we're on that
boomtown rats
and uh you know so i probably saw that
but i don't actually remember so i
should probably like
look into that because that sounds like
super funny
why was how was how is he being a [ __ ]
to him
they didn't i kind of feel like did they
not get along am i remembering that
wrong
like i kind of felt like they were
always kind of like had a little bit of
a
feud going on
dj maniac says i'm heading out have fun
kids okay well you have fun too
yeah we'll be heading out probably in
about like an hour or so
yeah dj maniac says martha washes and
the weather girls yeah that's right it's
raining men yeah they did a bunch of
songs but that's yeah that's like their
best known one
camera says i saw the eurythmics at the
fox theater atlanta in the early 1980s
one of the best concerts i had ever seen
i mean the arrhythmics were really
really good
that was kind of like in the early days
of mtv because we got um when i was a
kid like you know i probably brought
this up before my dad worked for the
cable company so we got mtv right when
it started like in august of 1981
and i was nine
and i got
immediately like as soon as it came on
buggles video killed the radio star i
was just i was into it i watched it all
the time
and
i kind of feel like the eurythmics all
that kind of stuff that was
one of the first
that some of the first videos the first
batch of videos that i remember watching
on mtv you know what i mean
like and that was 82 that was 82 i think
like sweet dreams it was the videos that
i remember most from that time period
were sweet dreams from eurythmics um
secular furs love my way
uh modern english i melt with you
um that was another one that was
closeted
dude from [ __ ] oh richard butler it's
your brother from the second look first
[ __ ] sounded great man
i love this actually [ __ ] that was like
easily one of my favorite like he just
sounds real fans from when i was a kid
when i was a kid the first time i heard
love my way in 82 or whenever that came
out like i saw it on mtv and i'm just
kind of like i bought all their [ __ ]
president gas
yeah
i mean [ __ ] all their shit's good yeah
they're like all their [ __ ] they they
started out like more punk more punk
yeah um because i bought their first
album which was called talk talk talk
yeah and that was kind of like uh that
was like just a more like straight punk
album and then like they kind of went
more post-punk new wavy like as it went
on
but yeah they're a really good band we
saw them live so i'm live yeah
several years ago yeah in a room full of
[ __ ] yuppies me and jen the only
[ __ ] goss there
yeah they sounded great live
good this when in florida
florida resorts
i think this is probably like 10 years
ago yeah but the thing about it was that
i think what i enjoyed the most i've
seen the cycle at first because i saw
them
before i met you i saw them a couple
times uh at
not visage but what's that other
firestone i saw him at firestone like a
few years before i met you two
but the thing about it is that richard
butler like the band and everything like
that they always look like they're
having the time of their [ __ ] lives
they're very they're they just seem like
they're into it and they're like super
enthusiastic
and that goes like a really long way and
the same thing like when we saw them
yeah at wherever that place was they had
a hotel
yeah it was like um
it was a hard rock hotel yeah it was
hard rock hotel yeah it's hard rock live
yeah yeah
and they were like really good and they
looked like they were just having like
at the [ __ ] they just they were in a
[ __ ] sea of people who didn't even
know who they were
yeah it's just like a bunch of people oh
we're just staying at this hotel and we
just wandered down here yeah and they're
like drinking some [ __ ] yeah
it was just like we were like up there
in the front going yeah president gasps
i [ __ ] rocking out and i [ __ ] walk
away and [ __ ] some foot and i we're
all gobbed out and some
some dude [ __ ] grabbed the back of my
jacket like then it turned around like
that and [ __ ] three other [ __ ]
three other jocks [ __ ] jumped on that
dude no no no no
leave him alone
maybe they thought we were with them
or something i don't [ __ ] know that
was a weird name it was a weird [ __ ]
weird night but i had the jocks
protecting us
it's weird man
it's weird that is that was very weird
yeah they thought we were with the band
i guess because you pulled on the back
of my jacket because we were walking
away we were the only guys
i'm like second three or four dudes
[ __ ] jumped on him no no no don't
don't touch him
yeah
remember that yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
funny that was like something yeah yeah
yeah
i was just go i mean
it was a great show i wish we would have
had like because i saw them at
what was that place was either firestone
or the edge do you remember the edge
it's not there anymore no no
but i saw them there but like before i
met you uh maybe
probably more than once actually
and you know that was more like a agothy
crowd
um so seeing them at hard rock live was
very strange because i thought that like
more gothy people would turn out but
they really did not all right maniac
we'll see you around bro he's uh he's
gotta go yeah
yeah i saw that
uh john smith said that boy george hated
the george michael's closeted didn't
fancy him kept making jokes about him
being gay in the footage oh i'm gonna
have to watch this
see i didn't remember that and probably
and he called yeah because he's just
like no well he's probably just like why
you being that way
john said that [ __ ] golden earring
had a great video to twilight zone i
loved it i used to like that yeah they
were really good i liked that song they
also did radar love didn't they yeah
yeah yeah they were also good
i also like falco in the original
[ __ ] german yeah in german not even
yeah
although the after the fire version
which was the english version the band
was called after the fire i like that
version too but the but falco he died
too actually
john smith says i remember second dog
first were pretty in pink oh that's the
other yeah that's that that song
is a [ __ ] great song but they have so
much other really good stuff well and
the thing about pretty and pink yeah is
that the original version of the song
was on i think their first album so it
was much more punky yeah now this movie
was actually based kind of on that song
or at least like molly ringwald
brought that song because she was a big
psychology first fan to john hughes
and said hey i want to use this song in
a movie or something like that so he
wrote
the screenplay kind of around that yeah
um and then they did another version of
the song that you hear in the movie but
there's actually like kind of a rougher
like punkier sounding version like that
came out in 81 i think but the movie is
actually sort of partially based on the
song john goris says psychedelic first
is one of warhol's latter day projects
if i recall that's possible wait were
they uh
say my name said where are those clubs
what state i think he's talking about
what we're talking about i guess the
clubs we're talking about maybe um we're
talking about florida where in florida
we're in florida central florida yeah in
the orlando area yeah disney and all
that yeah i mean all the [ __ ] we were
talking about like the edge that's not
there anymore um but there used to be
they used to do a lot of live shows
there visage uh has is long gone john
said that he never saw pretty in pink i
don't know you gotta see it it's good
it's a good song it's a good movie
yeah
it's probably i'm trying to think like i
mean john hughes movies probably pretty
and pink is my favorite jen lost says
ghost and use my favorite psychedelic
first oh that's so good yeah i was just
honestly other day yeah i was thinking
of
what's that one song they did i think
it's called uh run run run
yeah i think it's on their first or
second album
and i had that on my phone and i used to
like hear that on my like uh my walks
all the time and it's like that's a
really [ __ ] good song but that was
probably my favorite album of theirs is
the one that has love my way on it
but
uh which is called forever now yeah
forever now i mean that whole yeah i had
it on vinyl and then i had it on
cassette i had midnight to midnight and
i didn't like it when it came out i
didn't like midnight to a minute either
because i was more into their old [ __ ]
like i said i like they're more punky
well i went back later and listened to
midnight to midnight it had grown on me
a little bit yeah it was good it was it
was good it's just that had heartbreak
being on it heartbreak beat on it yeah
see i didn't love that when it came out
i thought it was a little too poppy it
was too poppy at the time but you go
back and listen to it recently
in recent years you go oh yeah it's
that's pretty good pretty good i think
that was the last album
because heartbreak b came out and at
this point this is what like i think
this was early 90s i want to say it was
like 91.92 somewhere like that and at
that point like mtv had a couple of
shows they had 120 minutes they had
post-modern mtv so they were showing you
know so you had like heartbreak beats
psychology first like so alive like 11
rockets you had like all of these kind
of like you know songs from bands that
were
kind of like underground or they used to
be and then they would put out like
these really poppy songs
and so i was like less into that yeah i
kind of feel like so when midnight to
midnight came out just like when the
loving rockets out oh bless you sweetie
no no that's my that's the back of my oh
i thought it's like i thought she's
sneaking it sounds like a sneeze but
it's not it's just that and like when
love and rockets put out their
self-titled love and rocket them i was
just kind of like well i like their
older [ __ ] yeah i was i was being like a
hipster but back to the reason why i
even talked about [ __ ] um
uh the psychedelic first is that
i never would have suspected that
richard butler was gay it just wasn't an
issue it wasn't the topic of the albums
or anything he just seemed totally
straight to me
you know
and there was nothing really gay about
any of the material
which
i guess that was the idea behind the
band and
did his job
you know [ __ ] if that's what they
wanted that's what that's what they got
um but when i found out he was gay i was
like man that dude's gay it seems
straight as [ __ ] to me
you know it's weird like i said i never
really thought about it yeah it never
came up it doesn't come up
in the music at all yeah just music
you know intelligent music all the time
i was just but i was kind of surprised
to hear it
you know yeah it wasn't i was surprised
of course you know [ __ ]
you know when some of the other ones
came out like when [ __ ] rob halford
came out i was like oh yeah i always
knew he said back in 79 that he was gay
you know [ __ ] just you weren't paying
attention to the lyrics you know
just another time
yeah and like i said it was something
like because there was a lot of that
going on in the 80s i kind of feel like
people didn't really focus on it
no you would have thought that robert
smith was gay if you weren't really
paying attention but he's not but he's
been married like forever yeah he's been
married forever like to his girlfriend
that he knew when he was 16. you maybe
would have thought that [ __ ] i think
they're still married you would have
thought that like half the [ __ ]
members of duran duran were gay no and
none of them were none of them were
they're officers
rhodes now he's gay
that was the straightest one
he was the straightest one
the pretty one with all the makeup was
the straightest [ __ ] one yeah well
see that's the thing you didn't he was
almost you just you're assuming based on
[ __ ] you didn't assume it yeah yeah
because all the dudes were wearing
makeup and had like crazy hair and [ __ ]
back then so you didn't assume that
anybody's like you're just like we don't
we don't you're assuming that that's
weird
that's not what he was
and he was the most gangster out of them
all [ __ ] little bitty pretty
[ __ ] with his [ __ ] hair and
his looking makeup and [ __ ] and that was
the one you couldn't if you had a hot
wife you just you couldn't leave her
with him
you know he was one of those
it was like prince you know prince same
way
sexually aggressive little [ __ ]
yeah that's how you do it you got to
like get in there like that sideways
john smith said i saw the breakfast club
at exactly the right age to do so i
think i did as well yeah and honestly i
mean the breakfast club actually
probably the breakfast club is the best
one but he made so many good ones but i
really liked pretty in pink because one
the soundtrack was amazing i loved ducky
i liked the whole
you know uh even though he was a little
bit stalkery from like today's
perspective but i liked the whole
uh poor girl rich guy although i kind of
wish she would have dumped that rich guy
because he was kind of a douche but you
know what i mean uh in the book she
actually ends up with ducky the book
that was uh written afterwards would
have been in real life that's what i'm
saying
because i kind of feel like
that rich guy he was like he was kind of
a turd to her
well i think he was you were supposed to
see that though yeah
you were i think you were supposed to
see how dumb teenagers are
and also can we talk about and i know
everybody's talked about this but the
dress that she made yeah for the prom
what the [ __ ] are you thinking girl come
on i know i get your crafty and
everything like that but
her friend
the punk rock chick who was who was
played by annie pogba hot as [ __ ] it was
hot as [ __ ] and didn't notice it at the
time the one from [ __ ] ghostbusters i
love her yeah she's she's my favorite
character i didn't notice a pretty
opinion i didn't notice at the time at
the time when i was young
how hot that [ __ ] was she's super hot
but she had like big spiky hair i was
like oh my god i'm so into it i love
this woman i love this song as soon as
you pass 25 all of a sudden you're like
oh no that chick's [ __ ] hot man
she's super hot and she's like in there
like in her fetish clothes she runs like
the record store since when since i sent
the nights tied up in the back of your
car yeah you know what i mean like she's
[ __ ] great in that yeah and like when
she turns into like a yuppie because
she's dating everyone i was like no
it made me so sad but then like she
gives andy like molly ringwald's
character her dress from like the 60s
and i was like oh i was like i would
have worn that just as it was
it was beautiful and she cut it all up
and made it into like this [ __ ] bag
i'm like [ __ ] what are you doing crazy
you should have just worn it like it was
it was like [ __ ] she could have worn it
like it was and done her hair like in a
[ __ ] beehive that had been [ __ ]
fantastic you'd look like the [ __ ]
b-52s that would have been great but no
but no what are you doing judd says
ducky was my hero when i was middle
school
he was great he was great granthar says
granthar let his kids watch weird
science recently their favorite scene
was when kelly lebrock turned bill
paxton into a turd
[Laughter]
can you believe that
can you believe
that hot ass [ __ ] woman was married
to [ __ ] steven seagal i can't believe
it
what was she thinking why his way into
that
he must have lied his way to hell or not
drunk her or something of course he
[ __ ] lied his way into that she
probably woke up one morning he's like
what the [ __ ] am i doing yeah what am i
doing i'm in bed next
i mean
what possible
what could he possibly have i don't know
to offer someone like kelly lebrock i
just i don't understand
judd also says some kind of wonderful is
a pretty great john hughes film yeah i
was really into that one too like a lot
of people kind of like dismissed it
because they were like oh it's just like
a gender reversed pretty in pink but it
had its own thing going on and some kind
of wonderful also had a fantastic
uh score so there's that and i loved
watts i loved that character
like she was [ __ ] great like
everybody made fun of her because she
was too
boyish but she was like all in love with
eric stoltz and
there was a whole yeah it's good if you
haven't seen it like i really really do
like the soundtrack of that too like
john hughes really did capture
i mean i know molly ringwald has come
out later and bit like you know some of
the stuff in there didn't uh age super
well i'm gonna say but um especially
some of the weird like racial
stereotypes
but i mean he really did capture the
zeitgeist
of growing up in the 1980s i think i
related to pretty in pink the hardest
and some kind of wonderful too to a
lesser degree because
i mean
the character of andy and pretty in pink
i mean she lived in like kind of a
shitty house like with her single dad
um she had like a shitty car which
honestly
i was kind of like i was kind of like on
her kind of thing but i was like wait
you have a car and a phone in your room
holy [ __ ] like you're you're like way
wealthier than i was when i was that age
but she was still like portrayed as poor
so
you know it was a little bit like okay
like i well i did have a phone in my
room
but
yeah but i didn't have a car until i was
in my 20s because i couldn't afford it
but
there was that but so i just i thought
that was kind of like funny but she did
kind of live in a shitty house and i
liked the whole like rich poor thing
because the high school that i went to
um
was mostly like
upper middle class people and i was like
very working class so i kind of got that
whole
you know and i wore like a lot of
secondhand clothes and stuff like that
and i got made fun of a lot because of
you know my cheap ass clothes and stuff
so i got
like uh so a lot of that like resonated
i guess
uh that movie huh you get another drink
it was out there
cookie wanted me to [ __ ] throw things
at her
[Laughter]
yeah she um
she's always like why are you guys like
constantly playing with me
she you go out the door and she'll like
run up with her little butt wiggling and
she'll be like brah like come on that's
her way of saying like she trills and
then she like runs down the hall come on
come on come on come on
she has like a little chicken and it's
like pick up the chicken and throw it
like i want to catch it
come here and brush me
let me sit in the window it's all that
kind of stuff
camp guy's talking about oh
i'm telling him everything i think he's
thinking about picking up some [ __ ]
oh my god i can't guys have my that's my
favorite line from where it says how
about a nice greasy pork sandwich served
in a dirty ash tray
i still say that every now and then
that [ __ ] makes me sad that makes me
laugh so much
oh my god
oh my god okay long duck dog yeah
yeah it's a little problematic it's a
little problematic i mean at least
at least that actor got work um
i just think it's funny because that
actor if you don't know
um
does absolutely not talk like that
so
which is funny because we were watching
karate kid the other night like we were
because louie sent us uh the steelbook
of karate kid so we were re-watching it
the other night
and pat marita if you guys didn't know
like he um again just absolutely not
talk like he talks in the movie
he was actually talking like his uncle
that's where he got that like accent
from but he just like talks like
an american you know what i mean he just
has like a regular ass american accent
so i just thought that was like kind of
funny
uh the end scene with watts was awesome
yeah i mean i really really like that
i liked that whole scene where he like
bought he spent his whole entire savings
like to buy those ugly ass diamond
earrings weren't they like cubes or
something try that and then is there
tequila in it no no no
i know how you try it
[Music]
yeah wait what flavor is that passion
fruit oh okay
passion fruit it smells kind of weird
like when i
i'm not a big fan of passion fruit it's
real strong though i mean i made him
almost half vodka is it yeah we got um
yeah we got some of those drinks we got
like tropical punch and i got like
watermelon lemonade yeah we went
shopping today we went down to publix
and saw that in the [ __ ] grocery
store
we've got a bunch of it's welshes
welsh just one of them is welch's no we
got one more welsh yeah and then we got
like well the minute maid was cheaper
yeah yeah but they only had tropical
punch and fruit punch welch's had like a
[ __ ] ton of different flavors but they
were more they were like three something
yeah and the um and the minute made ones
were only two yeah i got them by the
half gallon and i said jenny that'll
make good mixers
yeah because it's kind of sugary what's
so the mixers that's like yeah that's
it's good man that's just really good
plus like i said all i've had today is
like one single sandwich although before
we go out late late we're gonna get
somebody i should probably eat something
but we still have time it's eight it's
eight ten yeah yeah the one having some
eggs
oh that's like a like a uh egg and
cheese burrito or something like that
yeah that sounds good actually okay
or an egg cheese sandwich one or two
fast easy to make yeah well yeah judd's
talking about the last scene of some
kind of waterfall was that yeah i was
like i laughed when
so he gives her the earrings like he
tried to give him to to what's her face
it was back to the future
and uh she says no it was like she gave
him back to him she's like in your heart
you wanted to give this to somebody else
so he gives them to watts and she
he's like he finally figures out that
she's in love with him and like that
he's in love with her and she's he's
like i'm sorry i didn't know and she's
like well you're stupid i always knew
you were stupid
that like made me laugh so hard the
first time i saw that like she said it
like jokingly but also like not joking
bigfoot worship sets great show please
be careful
traveling to and from on the road again
it's gonna be all right we're not going
far yeah it's not far i mean we'll be
all right we'll be all right i hope
john gore says my problem with long duck
dog is that it's a faux chinese name
yeah and the guy seems more japanese
from all the signs and i think that
actor
where is that actor from like i've seen
him in a bunch of other things nothing
was supposed to be realistic back then
everything was all just a gag yeah it
does also be funny
that's true yeah
i mean that's it's crazy it's crazy
i mean the fact that he just
and then he ends up with
he ends up with that like huge like tall
woman with those big massive boobs
that's all like kind of manly and stuff
yeah
well there's a lot of [ __ ] that [ __ ]
shouldn't have happened but did happen
like we were we were watching we were
watching um we're gonna do we're gonna
do a review on it again but the the
first um
uh karate kid yeah i just i just
mentioned that yeah
and the director comes right out and
said me and jenny are going like those
two right there how could he get that
girl
you know i was always weirded out by the
like even back in the 80s i'm like dude
she looks like a [ __ ] child and she
looks like a porn star i mean she looks
like she's in her 20s and he looks like
he's about 14. yeah it's like super
weird well the director comes in and he
goes well we wanted this [ __ ] to be like
you have this like a dorky dude who's
just an annoying nerd that's likable
who ends up with this chick that he just
couldn't get and he he he put him next
to the director said he put him side by
side that's just like
he has no business being with that girl
okay it's strawberry shortcake and a
little skinny cannoli and that's that's
exactly what it was when we were kids we
were like
no that can't you know like what and
yeah that girl
for the era
even today you look at him it's just
like a super mix mix mismatch
he's a skinny little kid that looks like
he's 13 years old she looks like a
20-something [ __ ] porn star of the
era i mean i think they were pretty
similarly aged they were the same age i
think i mean i don't think there was a
huge difference in their ages but it
looks like there's a big difference yeah
because ralph macchio looks way younger
than he looked like a little skinny
[ __ ]
little kid which is kind of well that's
what they wanted i mean he even said
like on the materials he said we wanted
somebody that looked like a wimp right a
wimp with a chip on his shoulder that's
what he said yeah and uh the girl what i
don't know what i don't know what her
name is elizabeth
yeah elizabeth
was a short
voluptuous girl big boobs
pretty face
she was
if she was in porn and of course enough
for you young kids there was porn in
those areas she'd have been a christie
canyon type
you know a superstar
and she didn't look like a [ __ ] high
school girl at all she if you were to
say she's 27 you'd go oh okay you would
accept that
yeah i wouldn't think that like if you
told me she was in her mid-20s i'd have
been like
okay yeah
i mean i think she was actually 19
or 18. yeah it seemed like she was right
around that age right but so was he like
and then you you had they showed that
girl
next to the villain who ends up in
[ __ ] uh cobra kai he's the guy who
runs cobra kai yeah and you go oh okay
they could get together but not [ __ ]
ralph
he's a [ __ ] tall [ __ ]
buffed out dude they looked about the
same they looked like they could be a
couple you put ralph macchio next to her
like no they didn't look like a couple
well her head was a lot bigger than his
head just everything about her i think
that was what bothered me i mean well it
bothered me
the age difference like i said i know it
wasn't a realistic asia but like they
looked so much different right i was
like look at them together like she's
taller than him like she's like her head
is bigger i don't think she was taller
than him i think they were the same size
maybe it's just she was she just seemed
bigger and older yeah she seemed bigger
and older and pretty head was bigger
[ __ ] more
ready to go he looked like a child next
to her he did yeah yeah he did so i
think even back in the 80s that always
kind of like weirded me out yeah a
little bit
only halfway accepted it because there
was that
dynamic happening in high school
a lot of guys
like mike kowalski [ __ ] grapplers
knows who he is
mike kowalski was just like ralph
macchio that same build
that same dynamic right there he looked
like a child next to [ __ ] most high
school girls
it's not how he looks now but that's how
he looked back there well in general
girls tend to mature much faster so
i've seen that i mean we've all seen
that happen in junior high in high
school where like the girls will look a
lot older like the boys still look like
children yeah and the girls look like
almost like adult women
you know what i mean so it's like a
whole and you do see them dating
occasionally but
it is like kind of weird my buddy mike
looked like anthony michael hall out of
[ __ ] um when he was in a breakfast
club or a weird science breakfast club
like that worse worse he looked worse
[ __ ] he looked even more gawky all
right but he now looks like anthony
michael hall from [ __ ]
dead zone or from halloween kills yeah
he's like a big burly dude yeah
[Laughter]
no comparison
that's like funny what happened to that
dude no comparison
yeah
sorry i just thought of breakfast club
you know your problem you're a neo-maxi
zoomed weeby yeah what would you be
doing if you were not making yourself a
better person yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i've seen that maybe a whole bunch
of times but that that's just really
funny how
he was like so
typecast when he was younger
as like this gawky dork
and then like now you wouldn't even
recognize i i remember when
uh edward scissorhands came out which
was the first time that i'd seen him
since i'd seen him in the john hughes
movies and i was just like holy [ __ ] i
can't even believe that's the same
[ __ ] dude that he's just like he
looks completely [ __ ] different he
really i was like wow he filled out
didn't he
but you know
i still love like i still love his
character in like [ __ ] weird science
at breakfast club though although he did
he did take molly ringwald's underwear
well she gave him her underwear
weird science
no in uh
wait and weird and weird that was a
weird science that was um breakfast club
right no that was um
was it pretty in pink
because john cusack was in that [ __ ] too
no that was uh 16 candles it was 16
candles that's right 16 candles that was
the one
yeah because he was in that he was just
like the nerd that was like in love with
her and john cusack was one of his
dorky friends which is hilarious let's
see around john he's gotta go sleep get
laid there okay yeah i mean here it's
only eight yeah it's eight we're getting
ready to go in a bit
because i gotta make food for us too
that's right
yeah because we gotta leave about nine
inches
about nine ish
all right so if you all wanna buy jenny
a drink now's the time because we're
going to be leaving in a while
um
hugo says three o'clock high is another
high school movie that oh yeah i
remember that one yeah i haven't seen it
a long time though yeah
[ __ ] dean michael says i want jenny
to get that tara santana look back in
other words you want them boobs out
right
i [ __ ] told her i said jenny you need
to unleash those damn monsters on his
[ __ ] wit on these people you get this
like knives out but it's boobs out boom
yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ]
channel got a lot more traffic when you
when jenny was [ __ ] attacking you all
with boobs
yeah you get a lot of traffic get a lot
of super chats
sex sells that's just the way it is
i mean you know
what about your boobs
i got boobs
[Laughter]
let's see your boobs
actually no don't because yeah he'll
show him he doesn't care
[Laughter]
he doesn't have any shame no
[Laughter]
he doesn't have any [ __ ] no not at all
oh they're going faster [ __ ] bad killer
they're all laughing now yeah
we should probably review that one of
these days you know what we ought to do
some michael myers flicks not michael
what was his name uh [ __ ] russ meyer
split
russ meyers was the original bubologist
master of bubology he would study boobs
thomas mentor my man
put that on the [ __ ] silver screen
for you all to see okay
uh no boobs are great and um
it was uh
he he was uh
making he's forming monuments to boobs
in [ __ ]
in in cinematic [ __ ]
style you know man
put some boobs on the screen i just
thought how funny it would be
if somebody made like a round mount
rushmore a monument except it was four
sets of boobs yeah wouldn't that be
funny yeah
yeah from mount rushmore
russ
girls
myers
here's the thing somebody somebody could
buy a mountain and do that right
some people might say well that's some
sexist [ __ ] and [ __ ] that's lowbro
no it was a celebration of female power
all of russ meyers movies were about
female power
powerful female gangsters
beating up dudes and beating up other
girls and boobs flying everywhere it was
it was just that was his thing you know
what i mean and uh it was hyper
femininity that's that's what he was
into
powerful women with big boobs who could
catch this who could kick your ass they
could kick your ass they had guns and
they were gangsters
and it was uh kind of like a bdsm
fantasy you know it's it's fetish
oh yeah definitely definitely finished
i mean i i read his um
biography mm-hmm uh and it's very
entertaining yeah i'm sure i saw i have
it somewhere yeah it's in here somewhere
he kind of
coined the procedure of taking
hot strippers that were [ __ ]
physically talented and making them into
movie stars
you know tara satana was a
japanese
stripper japanese american stripper from
la had big [ __ ] boobs she was cute
and he turned her into a movie star
didn't we just see a movie that on
rifftrax the other day that she was in
the movie was terrible it was awful but
terrible movies but i mean she was good
in it though but yeah i can't remember
what the name of it was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was one that i just about
gestures and [ __ ] adventures and [ __ ]
yeah back in the 50s or 60s 60s i can't
even remember what it was about that's
like yeah i watched it was like uh it
was a riptrax one it was on i think yeah
but i i watched it because she was in it
she's actually the best part of that
movie well yeah she's the only good
partner yeah yeah
people couldn't act i mean
that's why you got to watch in our rift
tracks you can't watch it like without
without the commentary and don't you
know when you're talking about b movies
and
and
sexploitation type flicks
the women carried those movies and and a
lot of times they were the best actors
actors in the movies and tara could act
she could she could
well compare it
she could act in comparison to the
[ __ ] they have yeah it's all
relative
[Laughter]
but she could uh put on put on a good
show
you know just
there were movies of their time
you had to put it in that context yeah
yep there wasn't oh john gore says astro
zombies yeah that's what it is yeah it
was asked for zombies that's right john
kerry
john john carradine was in it yeah john
carradine would be in [ __ ] anything
yeah it was john d in fact john
carradine
was old yeah when he was born he was
born an old man yay he was because
seriously he was in some [ __ ] coleman
francis movies from back in the [ __ ]
1950s and the [ __ ] looked like an old
man back then yeah
astro zombies was [ __ ] uh mentioned
several times i believe by [ __ ] the
legendary glenn dancing well yeah
there's some misfits and christmas songs
sam hayne and so yeah
the movie is not really all that great
though but i watched the rifftrax
version and i was like the thing about
astro zombies the movie it's i mean the
title sounds amazing and i like that
she's in it and john carradine is in it
but it's boring as [ __ ] yeah like really
not a lot happening by today's standards
not a lot happens yeah if you were a kid
though a teenager teenage guy back in
the 60s you would have thought that was
great you just not we just weren't ex
exposed to everything that you're
exposed to now they didn't have the
choices
you just thought oh yeah yeah that's
great and then people are a lot more
discerning now yeah they're more
discerning now and then you would have
gone home and [ __ ] thought about that
[ __ ] hot ass mixed
half jacket
this big boobs [ __ ] you know that
would have been the only that would have
been the only takeaway exactly exactly
and that would have been the only good
thing so you're like yeah that movie was
awesome the move is awesome man you see
that girl yeah even though even though
it's like 90 minutes of like nothing
happening yeah yeah yeah
but and every now and then like he gets
ooh sexy and then like that's all it was
just beat off material for
[ __ ] young guys back in the 60s going
i wish i had a mixed japanese girl with
booze that big
[Laughter]
the rest of it they just like too and
like just toned it out yeah like like
like a big old vampire coming at me with
those [ __ ] because she had her eye
makeup done and everything you know just
mostly just kind of cultural takeaway of
the [ __ ] look
and really you know you're like oh okay
yeah that's something that could happen
you know
i can see if you saw that in your
formative years yeah that would probably
be but like watching it right now
though like watching it now yeah maybe
like a big deal
yeah well and plus like i said really
nothing happens it's like super super
boring yeah but it was fun on rifftrax
you're looking at it
you're looking at it from the point of
view of a person
of [ __ ] you know the 2020s you know i
mean [ __ ] we a lot of [ __ ] has
happened since then we've seen it at
home we've seen it all
if you were a teenager back in the 60s
and you saw that [ __ ] you thought you'd
saw a [ __ ] badass flick
because you saw something that you
normally wouldn't see
that's true which is a half japanese
girl with [ __ ] huge boobs it was
[ __ ] cool then you were like oh yeah
that's that's really what it all it's
all it really that's all it was
yeah
it was just a cr it was a fantastic it
was easy to entertain it was easier to
entertain
i mean it must have been because i've
seen like a lot of really low budget
movies from the 50s and 60s and a lot of
those are like yeah
a lot of those are like well that was
news that
that that combination of things would
not have occurred to a guy a young guy
of the 60s of the early 60s it just
wouldn't yeah
but it wasn't uh uh what
that wasn't the world that he lived in
they took him to another world
you know
but you know it's just uh
we're jaded
you know i mean we grew up seeing the
thing
and [ __ ]
gremlins and [ __ ]
porn and [ __ ] you know i mean it had
a lot to do with and [ __ ]
flash gordon and you know it was just
we were exposed to a lot more than what
those people were exposed to back then
but i can go back to look at what
they're seeing and try to put myself in
their shoes you know
historically well i try to whenever i
whenever i watch something from that era
right because i like bad movies yeah um
sometimes i need like rip tracks or mst
or something to like kind of like be a
middleman
um so i don't have to like sit through
it but
i try to put myself in the mindset of
those people the people that would have
been seeing this right because nowadays
like yeah nowadays
something like you know herschel
gordon-lewis's stuff
uh like blood feast would not be
shocking to anybody
but if you go back in time to when that
was made that was like a big [ __ ]
deal nobody had made a gore film before
so back in the days of for zombies it
would have been 16 17 year old guys
going did you see astro zombies like oh
yeah i saw that one
i saw that one that would have been some
underground [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah i saw that one did you
see her boobs
can we break the boobs the angle yeah
you see those boobs yeah did you
consider them i said yeah i did because
did you guys i considered them for a
while
did you consider the boobs yeah that's
that's what that's all it was but i can
i can put myself back in those days they
just didn't they weren't exposed to
variety you know so i can see what i can
see why
i can see why i [ __ ] i can see why
granddads imagined it
you know
yeah it was probably like a bigger deal
back in there's a bigger deal like i
said right but like i said watching it
now i'm just kind of like you're like oh
okay all right yeah uh camp guy says i
can't even remember a time before the
internet and i'm 60 plus years old yeah
i mean i'm i'm coming up on 50 i'll be
50 in september um
i do kind of remember a time for the
internet but it's all i don't know it
all just kind of like blends together i
do i do remember but
there was a lot of cool [ __ ] about the
70s and the 80s not gonna lie but if
somebody came to me and said hey want to
go back there no
no
um much easier shit's much easier
nowadays uh there was a lot of cool [ __ ]
back then there's a lot of real shitty
[ __ ] back then too
uh so i really would not want to go back
i mean i don't even i can't imagine what
i would do without the [ __ ] internet
nowadays but i do remember what it was
like without it but
i wouldn't want to get back to it
wouldn't want to get back to it
uh hugo said the ducky actor did another
movie called hiding out in junior high
or something oh yeah yeah um his name is
john cryer actually
and
i kind of remember that movie i think i
saw that
he wasn't in a [ __ ] ton of stuff was he
i kind of feel like you know it was
funny and i don't know why i thought
about this the other day but at the very
end of pretty in pink
when
molly ringwald's character is kind of
like no i'm going with the rich douche
and
ducky's like okay with it like i love
you enough to like let you go there's
their that whole thing and then he gets
like a consolation prize in the sense of
like this other cute girl that's like
hey come here you weird person
and that was christy swanson from
uh the original buffy the vampire slayer
movie
she was also in a deadly friend if you
remember that one
bibi
she was wasn't she like a [ __ ] well
okay it's been a while since i've seen
deadly friend
but i think that the whole premise of
that movie was that she was like this
girl and she got killed and then her
neighbor who was in love with her built
a robot or cyborg that looks just like
her
but she was like super violent and
killed an old lady by throwing a
basketball at her head right yeah and
like blew her head up yeah john's called
astro zombies that's right
yeah we've covered that yeah
we've covered that okay uh john gore
said howard hughes kind of did some
boobs playstation with jane russell in
the hello i kind of feel like jane
russell
she was so known for boob for boobage
that she did didn't she do like bra
commercials later on i kind of feel like
in the 70s sheet of broccoli yeah she
wasn't that big though i know but she
got it for the time for the time she was
in yeah so i kind of feel like and she
was um not shy about showing like not
whole boobs but like cleavage
decolletage so
um when they did was it playtex or
whoever was like making bras in like the
70s yeah
she i remember her being like in
commercials when i was a kid like seeing
her in commercials
i didn't realize when i saw her when i
was a kid i didn't realize that she'd
been in movies prior to that but then i
found out that later
that she was like known for her yeah for
you bubologists out there tara satada
was a lot bigger
yeah she's a lot better
okay um so we're at 8 32 and it's about
time for us to start to uh get ready we
got to get out of there i'll make us
something to eat and we'll leave okay
yeah because all we got to do is like
eat some food and put shoes on i can't
believe look what she did i know she
tore that [ __ ] up oh my god she tore up
my okay go ahead and shut it down and
i'm gonna start [ __ ] uh getting stuff
ready you wanna um
like an egg
egg sandwich or egg burrito which one
you want
uh
burrito i guess okay all right all right
so you guys have a good one we will see
you guys have a good weekend you guys
will see you guys on sunday probably
talk about the first karate kid because
we just watched it uh the other day so
we wanted to kind of like discuss that
because louis sent it to us
so hopefully like i said you guys have a
good weekend we're gonna go out in a
little while so if you're going out this
weekend please be safe and have a good
time and we will see you guys again on
sunday evening
good